Adam when did you fall in love with
storytelling good question my parents
are both storytellers I grew up with my
mom coming to school and telling stories
you know bedtime stories reading it come
from a large family so we'd all gather
around my mom would read stories to us
and I I would say you know ever since I
was a kid like like most of us were all
fascinated by stories we're all engaged
to my stories and I think it's one of
the literally being Homo Sapien means
you know that we have wisdom and
storytelling is the central part it's
what separates us from all the other
creatures in the forest where there's
certain stories that you gravitated
toward more than others I was a kid I
mean like for the where the wild things
grow yeah absolutely yeah absolutely
certain stories are gravitated I mean
you know I was a child when Star Wars
came out so like most kids in my
generation was obsessed with it which
you know later got me into Joseph
Campbell and a lot of those other things
that I was fascinated by the heroes hero
structure you know when you're a little
kid for me I wanted to be Luke Skywalker
when I was little and then when I hit
puberty I wanted to be Han Solo I was
until much later that I'd wanted to be a
Princess Leia oh that's good that's cool
I'll have an opportunity to talk about
that later
yeah yeah so currently you're an author
screenwriter story artist and director
which came first I would say a writer
and a painter or a writer and an artist
I was one of those kids that was
constantly drawing my parents would
bring home you know giant reams of
computer paper they started out buying
like sketch pads and things like that
for me and I would fill up a sketch pad
in just a couple days so my dad would
bring these you know in the old days
they would have like these reams of
paper with like the perforated edges so
he'll just bring that home and I would
just be drawing everything in sight I
draw flowers faces my hands anything
that was in front of me kind of
obsessively in a way and at the same
time I was drawing you know it's like
they always say that like whatever art
or skill you're passionate about it's
like you're married to and in that sense
I've always been a little bit of a
I missed because I love drawing as much
as I love writing but both of them kind
of been formed the same thing that it is
visual storytelling and so visual
storytelling has been central to it like
I had this one video that I am it's a
film strip I made when I was a kid and
literally it was just probably 16 frames
and I could draw directly on the film
strip and it was called drinky and
blinky I had this really I was grew up
in learning to speak in New York and I
had this really bad accent a bit of a
speech impediment so I always said Winky
Winky because I couldn't say my arse or
elles but so little by little was just I
did this story about these two aliens
and the classic frame like I recorded
the sound and everything that went with
it it was like this like I don't know if
you remember the old film strips you'd
have to do a beep like little beep to
twist it so anyways every time you do a
beep to kind of signal moving forward
and so I recorded the entire audio track
myself and it's embarrassing but you
know I mean it showed that like
literally at four years old I was
already trying to invent stories except
one of them was literally Twinkie and
Winky sat bail it was ridiculous but uh
but yeah I mean I guess I guess I've
always been fascinated by adventure I
think the more I matured as a writer I
became more interested in character and
how adventure really becomes the pretext
to explore a character and and then
eventually I think a lot of I became
fascinated by philosophy and things like
that like you know like many people that
are studying art and writing and I
became fascinated by kind of the the
connection between the way we build our
understanding of the world through
stories and now stories behind kind of
become like a filter through which we
interpret our experience like for
example my my video is called my video
series is called anatomy of chaos and
the reason is like people this is part
of the issue of I've had with Anatomy of
casts like they're always asking like
what it means and it starts off with
this idea
like the way our minds work is that we
are we have the kind of subconscious is
constantly drawing in information from
everywhere we are everywhere like you
walk into a room your subconscious is
picking up all the details it's reading
every single label on every single book
it's picking up like if this person's
shirt is wrinkled and then as our
subconscious gathers information it has
a kind of filter through which we
prioritize the information so it's like
we're swimming in the sea of chaos and
we're trying to make sense of everything
and ultimately our subconscious is kind
of filtering into our conscious through
narratives those narratives help us
develop a value system which help us
give us meaning and that meaning is a
kind of structure or an Anatomy so I
refer to it as the anatomy of chaos or
in other words how we use story to make
sense of the world around us and that's
ultimately where where the name came
from the problem is is that the average
person who's looking up how to write a
story is not looking for how anatomy of
chaos you know I had a bunch of friends
that were like you need to write how to
write a story how to write screenplays
which always seemed like the worst title
for I mean it's effective because it
comes to you know the algorithms when
you're like searching for for
interesting story or for for whatever
you're looking for but for me I tend to
lean more towards the poetic than the
practical so it's it's a big reason why
I like for example originally I released
it and it was like it was called the
anatomy of caste channel we've since
changed it to the art of story so it's
kind of more relevant to like the actual
the actual thing that we're like that
I'm the the disciplines that we're
teaching or discussing but it's still
called the anatomy Cass series within
that and you're still narrating - going
back to Mary four years old and you're
still yeah I'm still that you're right
yeah anybody watching this I highly
recommend they check out your channel I
mean yes twelve videos or eleven I have
about 12 videos I'm working on the next
one
okay in fact if we can discuss that
please a new announcement we
I've been getting a lot of requests to
release the transcripts of the different
videos and so what I've done is a friend
of mine actually took the time to
transcribe the entire series we
formatted it we're putting it into a
book and this week we're releasing it as
a novel or as a book so you'll be able
to buy you'll be able to buy it's called
the lost art of story as in Lost Tribe
Entertainment which is my production
company oh okay so it's and it's just
the transcripts of all of the videos so
a lot of people have been wanting to
read it as they go along or just look at
the lecture itself I also have a lot of
like friends that are deaf that can't
the subtitles for example aren't very
good with the algorithm so so the book
will be available and you know Brian
Koppelman once said that like every
screenwriting book is every one
of them which is my mind is only five
dollars so that'll be coming out this
week and it'll be available on Amazon
right now it's just ebook but we'll be
getting into print later on great well I
highly recommend to anyone watching the
videos because visually and if they are
able to hear you have with the music and
you intercut your own audio with you
know different scenes from movies it's
beautifully done they know and I noticed
that all the comments were like I'm
shocked that you don't have more
subscribers and I was shocked too yeah
so that actually kind of goes back to
the the fact that I tend to be more see
here's the thing so the impetus or the
the history of the videos was that I
went to CalArts studied film and I got
hired to teach there now I had sold one
screenplay to an independent production
company and I got to work with great
producers great writers got to work with
David Trottier came on as a consultant
and I learned a ton and so when I was
teaching the screenwriting herstory
classic hell arts I was able to take all
this information that I was learning and
try and teach it to students which is
that's when you really start to
when you have to communicate to somebody
else so I would teach I kind of set up
these curriculum with these lectures
kind of talking like the basics of some
of the different lessons that I had
learned and I was kind of had that like
in my reservoir or or my toolkit for
things I could work with and you know
also with writing it explores a lot of
the the techniques that I use so years
later when I was releasing my novel I
was profit margin I wrote it and
released it independently and in
researching a lot of the promotions for
your books and stuff I everybody kept
recommending you should start building a
following by doing videos and they
recommended how-to videos and things
like that and I was like well I mean
I've got this experience teaching at one
of the top film schools so I was very
lucky to have that and I'm like I'm just
gonna take some of my lessons put them
in these short discreet little videos
and that will hopefully kind of draw
attention to the novel which is funny
because the videos have kind of taken
out a little bit of life of their own
and now we've become their own book so
it's it's kind of this funny full circle
but but yeah so it's it's basically it's
a college course for a major film school
but it's completely free on YouTube or
$5 if you buy the book I was gonna save
this question toward the end but I'm
actually wanting to talk about this now
because you're talking about your
YouTube channel and so when I see that
channel and some of the videos I watch I
don't just see somebody that's putting
them online just to build a following I
mean you seem to put tremendous care at
least from my you know watching them
when I see work like that I'm like wow
you know I wish I can be that talented
do you feel satisfied with it it's a
good question thank you first of all
just reminisce you to say I think I you
know I want to keep getting better at
him i watch him and I see mostly just
the flaws like the special you know the
first two videos it's like one song
looping in the background and so lasts
about a year and a half ago I broke my
ankle and it was a bad break and
couldn't walk for about four months and
during that time that I was healing I
couldn't do anything except work at the
computer so and literally I took the
four months off that I was like staying
at home so I started I was like well I
just put up the book I can do these
videos so the funny thing is is I was on
percocet and vicodin the whole time I
was recording so when you listen to the
audio I kind of had this kind of that's
not just the professor or the the
lecture tone I was a little bit high
when I was recording okay I didn't
notice that but okay cool I'm I'm glad
that come it doesn't come off too droney
but but because of that like you know
I've been learning through the whole
process like you know there's lots of
audio issues there's some times where
the music's too high and I was never I
was always self-conscious of my voice so
I didn't like the the way my voice
sounded so there were times where I was
like and consciously like I love this
song I'll just put the song and then
people are like can you drop the audio a
little bit more because we can't quite
hear it but now you can buy the book and
you get the actual you get the actual
words on the page well let me some
people are what if they say auditory
learners others are visual so yeah for
me I think I'm probably yeah maybe more
visual but it's an experience to watch
them so I know you're working on it but
I mean I think no I appreciate that
like I hope that they're I hope they're
compelling like my attention span moves
very quickly so I noticed that I was I
tended to be drawn to videos that just
hammering as much information as
possible which is why I tend to just
jump in as quickly as possible and
that's why they're really dense like I I
took an hour lecture and condensed it
into the bare essentials in eight
minutes in the first few videos and so
they're dense but that's also why I
structured them in such a way that it
has this kind of
like a table of contents and it's you
know you can go back and re-watch
different sections if you just want to
look up like like plot points what is a
plot point and then you can just click
on it it'll take you exactly to that
section of the video so that way it has
like it has kind of a way to review it
like you'll watch it you're not it's not
intended to just watch once it's it's
you know they're there based on the
lectures and the stuff that I was
teaching so I'm hoping the principles
that people will revisit and it'll help
them in their techniques and disciplines
well I know they say that's a common
that that's the mark of a true artist is
that they're never finished with
something but have you met someone where
you were surprised to hear from their
own opinion about their work that they
weren't satisfied with it and it shocked
you because you were such you weren't
all of it yeah I mean you know that's
it's it goes back to this thing I am Not
sure I'm not convinced I believe in
masters or mastery you know that's
that's my video start off with that
quote from Hemingway that we're all
apprentices in a craft with no masters
the idea with masters is this idea that
it's kind of this illusion that you have
complete control of the work that you're
making and you know if you read the
journals of all of the people that we
regard as masters great painters great
writers all of them are they might be
further along up the trail but they're
still wondering what's over the next
peak and so in in the end it's all of us
are on this journey together to try and
find some sort of meaningful experience
so yeah I mean it's true I'm especially
when I finish a piece almost always the
second I call it done I hate it I want
to get away from it like I'll finish a
first draft and I don't even want to
think about it for at least two good six
months or a painting or something I'll
do the noil painting and then as soon as
I finish it all I'll see is the flaws
and then you know go back and revisit
and rework it and stuff like that and
the hardest thing for me is to let
something go you know that's why
deadlines are really good for me if I
have a deadline I'll work my ass off to
meet the deadline and that way I can
kind of have more control of at least
you know I have a point where I have to
let go so kill myself to meet the
deadline and then just let it go which
has taken time to get up
you know the expression like you oh
you're so hard on yourself
do you see em yeah it's guys I guess
it's I don't know whatever but do you
think that's almost imperative for an
artist because what if they're so
thrilled with their work then they don't
they don't work on it they don't try to
tweak it I don't know I mean I think it
really depends on the artist I mean you
look at some artists some of my favorite
artists love their work I do think
that's I know lots of artists that I've
worked with that they're just like Oh
everything I do is awful and they and
then you start wondering why are you
doing here you hated that much I love my
art I love the process of creating art I
love the process of writing I love
losing myself in story like I can't stop
and literally can't turn it off but
there's also a kind of self-awareness as
hopefully there's a kind of humility
that goes along with that which is but I
need to get better at it you know at the
core of storytelling I feel like at the
core of art in general is this kind of
desire to to excavate our own
subconscious and drought the metaphors
that mean something to us and then
ultimately it's like it's like drawing
wine from the grape from from the
winepress that the subconscious is the
winepress so we have this amazing drink
and then what we're looking for is
artists is the perfect glass to deliver
it to somebody else so that they can
taste it and that glass is structure
it's you know it's the it's John rrah
it's the tropes that we use it's
ultimately about that's that's the
vehicle we're using to be able to
communicate it to somebody else like for
you what's art how do you define art mmm
well something that has meaning for me
something that I can be lost in someone
else's existence and then you can see
your own and weigh it against it and say
whether my life is better or worse
whatever it's just we're all sort of
like these little things existing in
this world no one's more sort of what no
one's experience is more tragic or
incredible than another so we just kind
of get lost in someone else's world and
to see it from another thing because I
think we're so in ourselves we can't see
our own our own lives and how we do
things or whatever well I know I mean
that's weird I'm from the Bay Area it
didn't come across but I think just to
watch for me in terms of film or reading
a book so but but I that's great I like
that metaphor the perfect glass to put
the wine in so with art like I think
that's beautiful and like some of the
things you mentioned is kind of getting
lost or escaping something or engaging
from a completely different perspective
and I think that's really at the core of
of what art is for example art versus
science like my father's a scientist
he's also you know aspiring artists but
he works as a scientist he grew up I he
worked as a scientist I retired now oh
well he teaches now but the distinction
that I draw between art and science
what is it zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance I think I did actually yes
there you go so they have this
discussion about like techne and how
techne is the original word for art or
they what was it the is it a Latin root
could be Greek no I think it's Greek so
it and that is technology was the same
root as art so science is really the
process of extracting information from
reality and having some sort of
understanding art I believe is the
process of taking that information and
making it emotionally relevant and that
emotional relevance helps us build value
systems so really science is a way of
gaining an understanding of the world
around us art is a way of making it mean
something as we internalize it so art is
the process of internalizing and story
in whatever body it takes whether it be
a painting whether it be a film or a
novel all of these things are ways of of
ingesting and emotionalizing information
that informs our value system and you
said grade art doesn't necessarily have
to be escapism is that right I mean I'm
not sure I don't really buy into this
skip is impaired
I'm like in my video about entertainment
I talked a little bit about that and
entertainment tends to be a little bit
denigrated like it's like well you know
it's it's the lowest form of art if it's
just entertaining but the the discipline
of entertainment like I mentioned this
in the video that the root of it comes
from the Latin and today ten a day and
today between ten a day to hold and so
literally entertainment means to hold
your attention from moment to moment so
when you're looking at the art of
entertainment you're engaging someone
else's mind and inspiring them to begin
to open it to ask questions to provoke
them to project their attention forward
in time and that that question of what
happens next is really what when you
know if you get the audience to ask what
happens next then you're engaging them
and that means they're searching for
meaning and that's when it's open that's
that's really when the art is happening
because what's happening is they're
looking for an emotional value system to
internalize it into their own life and
that to me is the magic of story when
when we're finding a new way to look at
the world
so the escapism side though I do think
art can be escapist ultimately it's kind
of like it's like a magic trick you're
getting everybody to look over here
isn't this interesting look at this
thing all sudden it disappears but
what's really happening internally is
we're finding a way to make meaning in
our lives and and that's true watching
The Flintstones watching Spongebob all
those things it feels escapist because
it's not necessarily you don't feel like
you're doing work necessarily but the
truth of it is is great art is helping
you expand your view of the world and
find meaning in your life and and
engaging something that you wouldn't
otherwise do that this whole paradigm
that I'm talking about Connick comes
from this idea of like um are you
familiar with the Emile Durkheim he's a
sociologist French sociologist okay so
he was he's kind of the father of like
modern sociology and he built up this he
he had this theory of the sacred and
profane and in and this is this is where
I get in trouble but I I think he was
one of the great early thinkers about
the way we develop value systems and he
was largely talking about religion and
how with religion its defined by a group
of people coming together and circling
around sacred objects what he called
totems and totems were essentially
metaphors or though they didn't believe
they were metaphors but they're
metaphors they binded people together
and and the other counterpoint to that
was the profane the profane lake so the
sacred was that which was removed
according to Durkheim and then the
profane was that like the normal
everyday mundane life so like an example
would be the sacred would be walking up
to a sculpture that embodies a God and
lighting candles and have a very
conscious ritual experience and the
mundane would be doing dishes and doing
laundry so that would be the profane
versus the sacred now there's very in
trouble
I think it's he was looking at evidences
or things that relate to the sacred and
the profane
but he didn't it's not an adequate
definition of it the way I defined a
sacred in the profane as the sacred is
that which is vital to your survival and
the profane is anything that threatens
that hmm and we develop our value
systems internally from there now you
might be asking what does this have to
do a story and at the core at the core
it's we find meaning by that which we
prioritize right and we prioritize based
on our emotions so our our internal
value system is our emotional structure
or our emotional makeup that's kind of
the map of the emotions and and those
directly inform our moral values and
what story does is help us to engage
those moral values through an emotional
experience which is why an effective
story is innately emotional
and for example a scientific narrative
is largely just this therefore this
therefore this so a great artist to me
great art isn't necessarily escapist or
not it's essentially defines itself by
tapping into truths that resonate with
multiple generations
the way you look at metaphor is similar
view is is that it's a I see it as the
basic unit of a story it's the basic
unit of it's basically a representation
of something or a concept with emotional
value and that's controversial because a
lot of people would disagree with that
and I'd love to have that conversation
you know yeah exactly but all of us all
perception is based on this idea that
when we have a concept like have you
ever heard of Lisa Feldman Barrett yeah
she wrote this book called how emotions
are made it's fantastic I I actually
refer to her as her holiness Lisa
Feldman oh man he's so amazing I've
learned a lot from her um then she wrote
this great book and she talked a lot
about like the nakhon the contemporary
idea of how we developed concepts and
concepts are largely defined by our
goals or objectives like for example
this is a glass because it holds
something and we can drink from it so my
objective is to drink from it so
anything that is can we can hold liquid
and drink from is a kind of glass or
receptacle or Cup or something like that
so that's how we define things that's a
concept but it's not until it has an
emotional significance that we've
assigned an emotional significance
internally that it becomes a metaphor
and I believe that's true with any kind
of representation as soon as it has an
emotional connection in your
subconscious then its metaphoric so when
you know earlier I mentioned that a
story is about excavating or searching
your unconscious for the metaphors that
means something to you
what we're really trying to do is all of
us dream all of us try to find we're
constantly adapting to the world around
us which means our value systems are
shifting like as we adapt if there's
some sort of massive trauma it causes a
dramatic shift in in the way we
interpret the world around us story in
many ways is a way of engaging traumas
so you that's why you're literally
taking a character putting them through
a trauma and forcing a kind of shift in
their value system that's how we get
into character arc and that's ultimately
what a theme is a theme is basically
saying that the life is going to impose
certain traumas on you and we have to
adapt to it and that's that's ultimately
like where we find meaning so when I say
meaning like what is meaning a to you
well for an example I think meaning can
be contagious so let's say I went into
donut shop this actually happened to be
a donut shop near downtown LA they were
watching
is it a telenovela or yeah so they what
and I don't you know just a little bit
of Spanish there but everyone was
riveted they were saying in this donut
shop even the girl behind the counter
and so because of that I was like wow
what is it so that gave me some meaning
for what I was watching even though I
barely understood what was being said
and it was fascinated by the actresses
reaction what was happening I guess a
man was breaking into her her home and
no just watching up everybody wasn't
even paying attention to the coffee and
doughnuts they were all about what was
up on that screen that's so that's a
little bit of a tangent but then that
became the meaning became contagious to
me now because I'm fascinated by no I
don't follow the show I'm not sure who
the actress is but I'm fascinated Wyatt
why do they invest this money do you
remember the scene yes it was an actress
attractive actress was somewhere in her
home and there was a man outside
breaking in and the camera kept
switching to her being scared inside and
the man outside and almost seemed like
the man knew her hmm but that's the
meaning I gave it if then you didn't
understand the language so you're just
drawn into that and I was drawn into how
the people yeah so you saw everyone
around you expressing high priority
attention that's what attention is is
you're giving priority mental a kind of
mental loan to do that subject matter
and that's that actually gets into the
what I think is the most interesting
part of story is that it is contagious
it's story is about building group
values ultimately
which is where you know we get back to
to Durkheim again is that ultimately we
are building a kind of consensus a kind
of it's not Universal it's it's usually
group specific kind of value systems
that connect to this group like so these
metaphors become very important like
this girl who felt threatened and she
was trapped in her apartment
everybody had invested in her so they
had the concept of the girl and then the
emotional attachment to her but it's
like Joseph Campbell says like tragedy
is how they say that tragedy is the
attachment to forms and the shattering
of that attachment and then comedy is
what is it the effortless kind of
disregard or detachment from things and
I think at the core that's that's
ultimately where we're talking about the
emotionality of something also like with
Pilar Alessandra she's a friend of mine
as well okay and yes she's great she
always says that stories an event plus
emotion a room event plus emotion equals
story shows position as an equation I
love that because it's exactly true
without the emotion it's not a story
it's just a series of events
I'll albeit logical but it's not it's
not until it's emotional that it means
something so for me early we're talking
about meaning and meaning is the the
resonance with that central value system
that we all develop that each of us
developed that's sacred and the profane
and then all the priorities that
proliferate from there when we tell a
story we're entering into a contract
with the audience
hmm oh no from the video okay yeah can
when you talk about that what's this
contract can we get out of the contract
um sure
you pay a price for it so basically when
you're saying when you sit down and say
I'm going to tell you a story you are
promising something and and you know I'm
in the video I draw a comparison I use
the metaphor of your taking out a loan
from somebody and what you're promising
is that you're gonna pay back the loan
and that they will get interest for
their investment of attention and
attention is the currency that they're
at the
spending it's actually the probably most
important currency like real-world
currency that we're dealing with is the
currency of attention especially with
the internet especially the fact
especially in the entertainment industry
literally entertainment is the the
industry of pain getting people to pay
attention so what you're doing is you're
promising that it's gonna be worth it
there's gonna be worth putting their
time into it so your job as the artists
is not only to present the conflict in
an interesting way but to make it mean
something to them and that's that's
where it gets very subjective that's why
you can have some of the great
storytelling and only a few people will
get it because it's it's relative to
like whatever psychological dynamics or
whatever values resonate with them can
you give me an example of a story that
does pay off where the contract is
fulfilled and someone's obligation is
paid off and then maybe one that it's
not fulfilled hmm that's a good simple
one back to the future will he get back
to the future
right there you're making a promise with
that title usually the the contract
you're making with the audience is right
in the titles right with the trailer
will you get back to the future you're
you're promising that in some way not
only are you gonna answer the question
but that you're going to enjoy the ride
and then it's gonna mean something when
he gets there and I do think that that's
you know ultimately he goes to this
whole journey it's Michael J Fox who's
endlessly entertaining and then was it
Zemeckis who's just brilliant like it's
it's perfectly directed it's so much fun
and it's the movie that everybody's seen
so it's like I would always use it as
like the perfect example of just like
entertaining movie like it's just a
completely entertaining movie so I do
think it completely fulfilled a contract
you're entertaining the entire time and
you're and then in the end he gives you
exactly what you want in a way that you
don't expect and it's fun you know you
enjoyed it but along the way you're also
learning little themes like about you
know this high school teenager who's
learning to appreciate
his family and learning what his parents
went through and like that that
actually kind of resonates on kind of a
more subconscious level where it's like
you know he he begins to develop an
appreciation for the different
generations and then how he that story
continues on his own life
he's almost reliving his dad's
experience yeah in some sense he's
becoming like because he sees that his
dad was you know not the most popular
guy in high school and was bullied and
then he's experiencing itself cuz he
stands up to Biff so yeah so then for
another example that I think is is
actually a really interesting example
look at No Country for Old Men now the
thing I love about the Coen brothers is
that they're constantly subverting their
own the audience's expectations they're
they're playing with it they they play
with the contract constantly which is
where that alienates a lot of people but
the people who are willing to take the
journey with them they find something
incredibly like much more rewarding so
with no country for old men I don't know
if you read the novel as well okay
that's love Cormac McCarthy he's one of
my favorite writers I was compared to
like a if Hemingway and Faulkner had a
baby but he he so Llewellyn Moss he's
kind of the hero he's the underdog in
the story and you're following this
whole journey and the whole contract is
is it gonna mean something that the well
Llewellyn Moss is gonna find this bag
full of millions of dollars go on a
journey and change his life and
everything's gonna be awesome after that
um we're gonna get into spoilers here so
okay spoiler alert spoiler alert so when
he he goes to this entire journey and in
the novel they also did this as well he
gets to a point and the sheriff Tommy
Lee Jones character is following him
around and you think you're waiting for
this whole thing to build up to this big
explosive climactic payoff where it's
Anton Chigurh and Llewellyn Moss and
these they're both well matched and
they're there's this hero and this
villain and you're waiting for the big
standoff and it doesn't come and instead
Tommy Lee Jones drives up to a hotel
he sees just barely the periphery of
some standoff and well Moss is dead and
we never even saw it we just see the
dead body and immediately when I first
read it I had to go back and reread it
I'm like did I miss something because it
felt like I felt at first my first
response was I just got cheated they got
me to invest in Lamaze he's making this
huge sacrifice why did he do this but it
was the fact that he did subvert that
contract that he did subvert our
expectations and then when you see it in
the movie they adapted it perfectly
where it's also it's anticlimactic but
it's the fact that you're expecting the
climax that created the meaningful
resonance afterward okay
the after that when you start looking at
like what did it mean that Llewellyn
Moss just died and it wasn't a standoff
in fact his wife ends up having to pay
the price as well she ends up getting
murdered by Anton Chigurh as well and
ultimately it's this question you know
it goes back to the theme that is this
No Country for Old Men like is this is
this some evil that's ancient that that
takes out that has like no mercy for for
goodness or kind people so ultimately it
really comes down to when you're paying
off a contract you're trying to engage
their attention and if you do break it
you have to have a good reason for it so
and you know art is a bridge you know
you're you're trying to build across the
waters to the to somebody else's mind
and so ultimately you know every single
artist has different builds their
bridges differently you know Michael Bay
will build his bridge all the way across
so people can just kind of step on and
have a conveyor belt across and then
Kubrick will build this bridge halfway
across and the audience has to build
their bridge all the way halfway across
and they meet in the middle and then
you'll get someone like in vendors or
someone that you
it takes you on a journey and you don't
know where it's going and you're pretty
much building a bridge to where he's at
you know but it you know and everybody
everybody decides every artist decides
how far they want to build a bridge
across the water don't you think though
every writer thinks that there that
there is a payoff they make sense to
them but unfortunately to an outside
view they may not see that payoff no I
can't speak for other writers um I sure
I do think that there is you know the
basic economy of story if you promise
something give it in a way that give the
you know the old adages give the
audience what they want anyway they
don't expect but it really comes down to
the needs of the story what are you
trying to convey with your story you
know and I don't like imposing too much
of like to me what's really interesting
is when like finding the exception of
those rules until it actually till it
actually means something new you know
can you give us an overview of your four
act story structure so what one of my
favorite instructors that I worked with
his name is Ron Mita he taught a class
over in Valencia and he wrote SWAT and
then I think he sold some stuff he
developed robots for blue sky or
something really good guy and very
practical great writer very cool guys
amazing for pitching as well and he had
this he was the one that introduced me
to this idea of just twenty-four plot
points and and he said just you know
literally just write down 24 just 24
numbers and just put PP plot point plot
by plot point and then break it down
into you know the first acts and then
you know most people say first second
and third but everybody divides it at
the midpoint now it really comes down to
how do you define an act and in
researching when I was working on the
videos I was trying to come up with a
good definition for act and you know I
looked at Robert McKee Truby Trottier
a lot of the greats and I couldn't find
a very clear specific definition of an
act so I you know I'm ridiculously
pedantic so I really tried to come down
to this boil it down to its essence I
try to be as precise as I can with the
terms and definitions like for example
inciting incident that words always that
terms always bothered me just because
technically every single sequence has an
inciting incident has an incident that's
inciting the next behavior a Snyder will
refer to as the catalyst a catalyst is
where you take two elements a chemical
reaction that's already going to happen
and a catalyst speeds it up so what
you're saying is that the catalyst is
going to take something that's
inevitable and enhances it that's why I
call it the impetus and impetus is a
force that moves that motivates movement
and that's which is a very specific
thing that happens once in the
screenplay
so that and that's you know that's my
terminology that I use I think whatever
metaphor helps people make sense of this
story and take care of the central
elements that's fine so Ron Mitas
approach was basically put the 24 plot
points plot point six is end of Act one
plot point twelve is a midpoint plot
point eighteen is your low point and
then plot point I think it was twenty
one is your climax and then after that's
falling action very simple and it's like
we would we would literally just sit
there and plot out a story in an hour
and it's it's super pragmatic so from
there it really came down to trying to
understand all right
if we keep dividing everything in the
midpoint like Pilar for example should
use act a 2a and 2b and it kept on
begging this question what is an act so
in your mind what is an act how would
you define one what is an act okay well
it's not really a scene but it time it
sets you up for one part of the journey
okay so let's just say there's a story
of someone going to college and maybe
there are a fish out of water and they
get a scholarship and they don't
we belong in this world and so the first
act or the second act it more than
others say the second act would show
them arriving with their stuff at the
campus and knowing how they're out of
place knowing how they're not gonna fit
in with the culture and so you see them
kind of scared with their box of stuff
maybe being brushed aside by busy people
hmm
and so that's establishing the world of
that college and they don't feel like
they fit in and they kind of know they
don't and everybody else knows they
don't fit in either but somehow they've
been able to go there so that's the long
winded way of setting up maybe that
would be the second act I don't know it
could be I'm jumping ahead too much but
no I mean I think you just described two
acts okay okay so where would you divide
it that's the big question and when
everybody said you know there's people
like like Dave and Friends Oni he came
to Cal er to gave one of my favorite
lectures on story ever and he was like
3x structure there's no such thing
as ax you just understand story you get
into character and you throw conflict at
them and they pursue their objectives
and don't worry about ax and that's fine
now if that works for you that's awesome
I don't like to me all of its modular
all of it is use it as assets that help
you write and anything that's holding
you back from writing let it go you know
has this kind of it to me I like to
understand his things as thoroughly as I
can I learn very slowly and thoroughly
and then let go whenever the story needs
to take its own direction so the way I
look at an act is essentially defined by
strategies so a character the the first
act as a character has a specific
strategy which is their normal daily
life this is the value systems that they
that have gotten them to this point in
life so when the impetus comes in and
throws their life out of balance they
find suddenly that they have to they
start to negotiate it and try and be
like well I don't want to change my life
I don't want to do anything but the
second they cross that threshold and
begin to shift into a new strategy then
they've crossed into a new act so what
I've found every single time is that
- for example you usually have a
character that's you know trying
something new like Tootsie you know I
watched that as a kid it's so great I
think is brilliant
so you have was Michael Dorsey who's
dressed as Dorothy Michaels and he's
having success and everything he's doing
is bring him more and more success and
it looks like hey this new strategy is
working before that a strategy was I'm
gonna be a difficult actor until no one
will work with him so he hits his
breaking point
alright I'm gonna just as a woman and
commit completely to the role and and he
sees nothing but success until he at the
midpoint when everything that he's doing
feels like it's paying off but
ultimately betrays his authenticity so
it's at the midpoint where basically you
feel like you're getting everything you
want and this can is completely
subjective to the needs of the story
this is just generally how the how the
structure tends to go but when you hit
the midpoint often you're you learn that
you are as far away from your original
objective as you could be thinking that
you're just about to achieve it
generally speaking and that realization
whatever that is the introduction of a
new conflict or something like that
creates a kind of shift in strategy and
usually that strategy is very like
frantic and coping and so all the value
systems that had informed that earlier
strategy of hey everything's gonna work
you hit the midpoint and it's failing
and you just come tumbling down the
mountain so you get down to the low
point because all that the first two
acts are all about set up and then the
second two are all about payoff so
that's second that that third what I
define is an act with what is to be but
I just go back three it's easier that
way is really just a strategy of
collapsing down the hill until you get
to the low point so all of those choices
are paying off but for the bad what do
you think a lot of new writers kind of
not go wrong but have trouble with the
line in terms of maybe two and three the
line
when sort of that that moment where you
think that they're going to achieve this
payoff that they came to see the movie
for mm-hmm but it actually that's the
beginning of a new set of issues and now
it's going to take you in a brand new
direction what do you think a lot of
writers have trouble when it comes to is
it is it setting up the first act is it
is it where it's not compelling enough
or it's too much drama in the first act
and we need a little bit of a build I
we'd almost have to take that a
case-by-case scenario I'm generally
speaking I'm not really sure like where
so many people hit the same problems but
a lot of it comes down to generally
speaking yeah if you're paying attention
if you've invested the most important
thing is if you've invested in a
character and you care about what the
character wants you understand what the
character wants and you understand
what's at stake if they don't get it
you're free to do anything you want you
can play with start to throw away
structure altogether as long as you have
that like Sorkin says worshipping at the
altar of intent and conflict is that
actually a might quote sound a little
better but it's it really comes down to
understanding the nature of character
every scene has to have a kind of
emotional motivation and if it's not
emotional then we're not we're going to
disengage it's not just it's not just
conflict it should be conflict that's
increasing as we're going along so I
mean you know I see a I see a lot of
television a movie I mean right now is a
great time for writers there's so much
good writing there's so much really
strong writing a lot of it comes down to
pacing a lot of it comes down to really
making sure that the audience is with
the main character and that their
choices are making sense and that that
you care about how this is going to
affect the way they're moving forward
but I think if you're tracking that and
most you know most writers we're all you
know we're delving into ourselves to try
and pull out this meaning a lot of it
like for example working with with
producers most of the notes that I'll
get tend to be kind of you know just
tracking like does it make sense that
this character would do this at this
time
you know and it's about trying to
project and project yourself into the
character and understand the intentions
and if that's consistent with your
overall character profile I have a quote
here and that is from William Goldman
from his book which lie did I tell and
he says you have to protect your writing
time you have to protect it to the death
so are you protective of your creative
time and how so
yes okay
so I've never I'm not one of those
people that have a difficulty with
motivation I'm like a slingshot I have a
my rubber band as always yeah my rubber
band is always drawn tight like I'm for
me it's not a question of will I be
motivated to do it it's it's a question
of when can I get to it so I'm I'm a
little bit obsessive too so I don't
really follow I don't have much of
writer's block is a real thing I don't
believe writer's block has anything to
do with motivation or anything like that
a lot of it just has to do with like
baking your metaphors
in your in your subconscious until
they're ready to come out and present
themselves as a meaningful experience so
for me I don't write everyday I write a
lot I'm very prolific but I spend most
of my time in Storyville you know like I
spend most of my time kind of in this
meditation or concentration like for
example I you know while I'm painting
and drawing it's like one part of my
brain can be focused on painting drawing
working on storyboards or something like
that and then the other part of my brain
is sitting there plotting out the next
scene and connecting all these different
things so a lot of it comes down to I'm
constantly thinking about story I'm
constantly coming up with stories I've
have a list of more than a hundred
different like novels screenplays comic
books short stories that I'm work
right now I'm you know juggling three
different two features and the two
pilots that I'm writing actively one in
particular that I'm really excited about
so as far as protecting my time arts
always been my priority like probably
some friends aides they might be a
little bit of an unhealthy attachment to
my heart because I tend to be a little
obsessive and but you know it's what
brings me meaning it's it makes nothing
makes me happier than sitting down and
writing a great scene and then having
somebody read it and then making it
better you know and it's it's also
making a beautiful painting or shooting
an amazing scene that like just nails
exactly what I'm going for or cutting
the pieces together like editing and
stuff it's just the process of art is
magical to me so for me it's I find so
much fulfillment from it that it's most
of the time I can't wait to get to the
cafe and write or I can't wait to get to
my chair and write or I can't wait to
get to the computer and draw our paint
so it's but I I know that like a lot of
people do struggle with that I just
haven't been one of those people that do
I think it's great at least you're not
making someone else your higher power I
mean you're making your art in some
sense yeah I think that's actually great
because that's something that's within
you and you're not depending on another
person for it so actually I think that's
healthy but has there ever been a time
when you feel like you you're not
spending enough time on creating
something whether it's painting writing
and you're like I need to defend my time
to do it and I need to make room for it
well like I said before in the in the
sense of like I love painting I love
drawing I love working on designing
comic books I love designing characters
modeling things like that but I made the
consciousness or choice that right now
the best thing I can do is invest in my
writing I spent a lot of my career
working on other people's stories and
other people's like you know I get to
work on Kung Fu Panda legends of
Awesomeness and monsters vs. aliens and
like that and it's been amazing I love
working in the story Department I love
collaborating with producers and other
writers and stuff but um I've made a
very conscious effort to for example
I've made a very conscious effort to
make sure that I'm focusing my
discipline where it's going to pay off
so so for example right now I'm working
on a television show I've been working I
wrote a pilot he's read it flipped over
it we're working together and we're
currently shopping it around and we're
very excited about it
but uh you know what I want to pitch it
to you I'm gonna hear it okay sure cool
do you want me to pretend I'm assistant
or okay well actually this can tie into
a little bit about how the like okay so
the biggest thing we're looking for when
we're when we're writing is that we're
trying to you know pull the metaphors
from ourself and make it mean something
to somebody else and ultimately that's
talking about theme theme tends to be
essentially moral in nature now a lot of
people like for example Robert McKee he
he calls it the controlling idea and I
like that he approaches it that way
because what do you like especially
during that time there was kind of this
tendency to be like we don't want to
moralize stories because when you try
and use a story to convey a moral it
starts coming off as preachy and then
you disengage from it and then you don't
buy into it so it's it's good to have
that kind of removal but at its core it
really is a kind of moral experience and
by moral I mean something that has
survival value a principle a principle
of the way the world works with survival
value so for example if you lie it ends
up biting you in the ass so that's a
claim about the way the world works or
the way universe works so if you tell
this if you tell this lie people find
out about it and then it catches up to
you so what we're doing essentially is
every single story is
essentially expressing a kind of moral
value that moral value is the theme so
the character is essentially there to
experience the rules of the universe and
then adapt to whatever that moral theme
is so let me see if I understand this
I'm gonna take the example pay the
consequence of the morality right okay
like Norma Rae I just re-watched that
Norma Rae Sally Field you have to say
okay darn I was gonna say it has so many
themes in it it's not just like this
feminist sort of movie there's also the
theme of sort of like xenophobia I don't
know if that's actually a theme but this
union organizer comes to this small town
where they need that mill that's where
all the jobs have been for years that's
where everyone's families worked they
don't want to rock the boat
with the owners if they try to like
strike out and get better wages dip
better working conditions it's gonna
bite them because they they'll just be
expendable so I guess I'm trying to say
is the theme of that movie we would
think is more about her standing up her
standing up to her father her standing
up to some of these men that if maybe
use her or whatever she's willingly
allowed that but it's also about seeing
a world that's outside of this small
little microcosm that you've been in
yeah you know she's only seen this
little small town this this hard mill
working life where the conditions are
bad I'm trying to think of what the name
of the theme would be as you said it's
it's a moral theme is about sort of
morals yeah so what's immoral to you
more well is it about values is it about
I consider stealing wrong let's say I
see something of my neighbors that's out
there that's accidentally there does
that mean that it's okay for me to take
no mm-hmm even if I don't like the
person I don't want to take it because
it's wrong why would it be wrong because
it doesn't belong to me I didn't pay for
it and what are the consequences of
doing that maybe nothing but I would
know about it and I think that's where
that might form the way you see the
world and your behavior and how I look
in the mirror myself yeah because then I
feel like I don't know if I can justify
that to myself taking something so it
might carry on certain individual
consequences and then you pay a certain
price for that even if this person
didn't know it
good yeah so I defined more of morality
as the rules of survival right and a
theme is a rule of the universe
so what we're constantly trying to do as
homo sapiens is we're trying to find out
how the universe works and the best way
to navigate it and it's through
narratives that we learn these value
systems that's why we're constantly
sharing these news stories because we're
constantly every single day trying to
find out how the world has changed so
that we can adapt to it and it's always
been this constant rate of change and we
end story is the mechanism for
adaptation that's why you really don't
buy into this escapist approach so so
theme being these rules on the universe
like every story has multiple themes to
it but I would say that a very
compelling story tends to have a clear
hierarchy of themes so what's a good
example we'll start with the Back to the
Future okay it's simple like what are
what are what can we extrapolate from
Back to the Future like what what what
are the rules of survival that we can
learn from Back to the Future oh there's
so many um it sounds like some of it's
about family protecting family mmm and
then learning your history mmm okay
having a better understanding of
yourself through your history and then
it is another sort of a
fish-out-of-water scenario yeah not
understanding the social mores and rules
of that time frame of that area cool so
you're pulling a whole bunch of
different rules of the universe that he
had to deal with the Marty McFly had to
deal with you essentially start out with
a character who's always late he's has a
little bit of an inferiority complex
he's seen as a loser by the principal
and all this stuff and so he's in a bit
of this shifting identity he's his
identity is like why is my life so
miserable how come I don't have
everything I want
which we all identify SAR and then by
him going back in time he starts to
learn that it was the choices of his
parents that directly affected
he was and by throwing himself in the
middle of that those choices begin to
shift and evolved and then you know he
gets to have a fantasy of like what it
would be like if things were different
so at the core of it usually what we're
looking for is one central theme that
informs everything I that's usually
defined by what I would call the moral
imperative which is the rule the rule of
survival that informs the entire story
so ultimately he learns that he
shouldn't with time or time will or
they'll have to have to pay the
consequence but ultimately through the
civil experience he learns that by
getting to know his parents in a
completely different way by identifying
with them at the same age where he was
he sees that they had an opportunity to
become to be people he would actually
care about rather than just being kind
of his parents and they're boring
they're actually people that he would
have interacted with and cared a great
deal for and then when he comes back he
sees how different everything is which
always has a little bit of an irony to
it I know but you see how they were
setting these roles and how he just saw
them as one way when they were sort of
these tragic roles in yeah you know but
what do you think his relation to doc is
what's the theme there I was always
fascinated by doc yeah what do you think
that is where we fascinated by much
because he was this sort of brilliant
guy that no one understood and people
were sort of afraid of him like him he
was almost evil but he wasn't he was he
was misunderstood you know they people
always say oh he's not a bad person he's
just misunderstood yeah but it doesn't
really seem like a bad person I I mean I
love Christopher Lloyd but I always felt
like Doc was a bit of a device like he
was I mean what was their interaction I
mean it eventually over the sequels and
stuff they started to care about each
other but ultimately you're always
wondering like why is this teenager hip
hanging out with this doc but it works
for the story you know if you just you
just buy it
invest in it but um but yeah ultimately
with stories we're looking for a central
theme that informs all the other themes
like for example the Royal Tenenbaums
you know essentially it's about learning
to love people like learning to let
people live their own lives and still
love them regardless because Roy was
always trying to control the way
everybody behaved and that ended up
causing this massive identity crisis for
his entire family until everyone's
miserable depressed and separated from
each other so it's when they come back
and he's like tries to reconnect with
all of them that he starts to impose his
old value system he tries to manipulate
people because he doesn't trust them to
love him so it's not until he learns if
I just love them for who they are if I
just let my son and adopted daughter
fall in love with each other and without
judgment then they then they're gonna
figure it out for themselves and they'll
love me regardless and that was like
that was the core lesson that he needed
to learn which is that you know accept
people for who they are and then then
you can love them for who they are
without trying to change them into
something else and so that I would say
that's the central theme and then every
other story after that like for example
Luke Wilson's character
Ricky Tannenbaum anyway Luke Wilson's
character the ten Imams he his central
theme was he felt extremely imposed upon
by his parents values that's why you
know he wore the headband like his
identity of success or his identity was
being a successful tennis player and so
he always felt like he was carrying
around the baggage of his parents
expectations which directly informs his
his deeper inner desire which was that
he was in love with Margo and so it was
through this process of learning to just
let go to let his heart be broken and
then eventually the royal learned to
love him for who he was that he would
that they were able to let go of this
baggage and so that would be kind of a
supporting theme that ties into the
central theme which is letting people be
who they are and then loving him
regardless
do you outline every story that you
write yeah I'm yeah I'm pretty thorough
with my outlining I tend to I'll spend
quite a bit of time outlining before I
even write the fold like I usually have
a complete full outline and then jump
into the story so I'll have a really
specific idea of the objective of every
single scene and ultimately it saves me
time when I first started writing I was
anti outline I kind of had the attitude
you know it's the young attitude of just
like you know I'm just gonna write and
my my guts gonna tell me what's right
and what it's meaningful and stuff like
that and that works for a lot of writers
but I noticed that I would hit a lot of
dead ends and I became emotionally
attached to those dead ends and then it
became really hard to rewrite until I
just drove my stories off the cliff and
so little by little the more I you know
honestly that Ron Media 24-point thing
was huge because it was so simple you
can literally sit there and just plot
out a story in an hour and you'd have a
really good idea of where I was going
and then from there you're you know
that's to me that's when you go from
like you know discovering your story to
actually becoming craftsman or a class
person where you're working on the story
and taking control of it and then you
start to take a step back and then you
know it's almost like a render machine
you're rendering your story before you
ever sit down and write it so then the
script really just becomes kind of a
secondary artifact of all the work that
you've put into it so yeah I spend a lot
of time outlining it it's and it's you
know a lot of people feel like it takes
away from the creative process usually
that's kind of the writer saying well I
want to be in the audience too and I
want to experience and be surprised by
it but outline who doesn't take away
from that because what happens when you
sit down like you've outlined you've got
your outline right here and then when
you're writing you put yourself in the
moment you're you're in the skin of the
writer or the character and you you're
experiencing it and then if your gut
tells you to try something different try
something different see where it goes so
you're still you know the whole
Gardner versus architect the pan servers
a plotter kind of thing I call it what
is it the bee assassin versus the
Berserker basically the idea that like
the the planner versus the person that
just sees what happens next and I think
it's important to to understand the
consequences of the choices you're
making but the whole process of writing
is an experiment art is an experiment
and the out the only thing that rules it
is do we make it emotionally resonant
for somebody else and as artists we get
to decide how much that is like how how
we build that relationship if we want to
do it is a little like for a living then
we become responsible to those people
that are investing in us and that's
that's when you want to be able to to
have control of your craft that's when
you want to be able to you know climb
the mountain know how you're gonna get
up there cuz you gotta meet a deadline
you know it's there aren't a lot of
producers that are gonna be like alright
you know we needed this three months ago
and you're still just kind of wandering
in the weeds but a lot of the process of
writing is experimenting in the weeds
going into the weeds and then stepping
back and the trick is just not not
panicking when you're in the weeds and
saying okay this is part of the process
let's step back and look at the let's
look at the outline and see if this is
gonna work so for me it feels like it's
like like a map you're zooming in and
you know you can do the the street view
where you're in the character and you're
just driving along and you're like yeah
I feel this I'm going through this
Street and that's when you're writing
but then you pull back you zoom out and
you see the overview of where you're
going and that's the outline so do you
think with without an outline a writer
backs themselves into a corner a little
bit I mean we're all vulnerable to that
even with an outline where were
vulnerable to it
but again I don't believe in any right
or wrong like there's this one writer
Bob signs he's amazing he says he
doesn't outline he's successful writes
great stuff he just wrote
extra-curricular and it
fantastic I read the script it's so good
and he he does an outline but he knows
how to write he gets he gets where he
needs to go and he knows how to tell a
story so it's like it's right what works
for you is fine the important thing is
to be able to to sell it to the
producers to engage the people that it
that that need to be engaged you're
writing for readers largely so you want
to learn to the language of what they
expect but within that you know it's
it's whatever gets you there I don't
think you have any obligation but
generally speaking the average person
would benefit from taking the time to
plan out where their story's gonna go
have a good idea of how it's going to
end and then you know work toward that
in the past have you introduced that
twenty four point system to some of your
students and yes surprised yeah actually
my first in my first video I introduced
the 20 for plot points and then they
break it down into acts and the
sequences and then scenes and everything
like that so it's um it's just a really
simple simple kind of like a lot of
people they'll stare at the blank page
I've never understood the staring at the
blank page because by the time I'm ready
to write a scene
I've already had like pages of writing I
can't it's like the slingshot you're
just like slowly like preparing like
getting all the scenes getting the
character getting the plot the conflict
you know what every character wants so
when you sit down you're ready to write
you let go and you're just flying you
know but it's but it really comes down
to everybody discovering their own
process you know and I'm not a purist
like lots of people don't outline and
they're very good writers are very
successful and a lot of that's the
intuition or their experience that
informs it we talk about text subtext
and context what does each item mean
yeah well that's a big subject text
subtext in context so ultimately it is
about a character wanting something
right every story's about a character
wants them wanting something and then
facing a conflict to get it whether they
get it or not
so when they want something they have a
desire that desire is expressed through
subtext if I want this glass of water
I'm going to take the action right so
the subtext is that you can infer I'm
thirsty or I'm looking for some sort of
like physical distraction to keep my
hands busy or something like that and
the gulping is part of that too maybe
there's I'm about to confront you on
something yes sir you know or I'm your
boss or you know whatever I'm an
ex-girlfriend me there's just so many
things and you're like you know yeah
exactly she's gonna say to me so a lot
of that is about interpreting we we are
guessing what a character wants from the
behaviors they're exhibiting right now
the context is simply the worldview the
situation they're dealing with right so
we're sitting in a room right now we
have we all have different objectives
and so that this the when the character
so the context is literally just like
the plate that you're serving everything
on like I compare it like visually it
came up with the metaphor of creme
brulee just use a visual metaphor where
you've got the plate as the context and
then you've got the brulee or the the
creme the cream as the subtext and then
the the top layer that's burned and
scorched brûléed is the text oh that's
great so the idea is basically what
we're seeing is words right and those
words often are in complete
contradiction of actual intention but in
some way were interpreting those words
as a kind of behavior so most of the
time like for example it's part of the
reason when I'm writing the last thing I
do is write dialogue that was another
thing I learned from Ron Mita you want
to be able to well do whatever you want
but for me I like to have the characters
intentions very clear and the conflict
that they're gonna be facing very clear
and what we're constantly trying to do
is there's this one there's a one book
called character and viewpoint
where it talks about how essentially you
know we're all like chimpanzees in the
wild and when they're in when they're in
the jungle and they sense that there's a
threat they run away and the first thing
they do as soon as they feel like
they're safe
the very first thing they do is they
stop they turn around to see where the
source of danger is so that's when
they're completely engaged the whole
chimpanzee metaphor is basically that
we're trying to interpret the intention
of things that are around us so we're
we're we're projecting what we think
that person wants by the way it's
behaving so we're trying to determine
whether it's a threat or whether it's
safe whether it's one on our side or
against us that kind of thing so
ultimately what we're looking for with
like with with dialogue is we're trying
to see if we can believe them and the
most interesting characters are
completely unaware of what's actually
driving them you know like they're the
whole time like Indiana Jones is going
through all of these ridiculous Hoops
not really like the whole time we were
wondering like why is he taking on these
Nazis why is it being dragged by a chair
just so that like some something and
make it into a museum ultimately he has
this really you know stuff that depends
how deep you want to go with Indiana
Jones but he has this kind of drive to
its genuinely emotionally upsetting to
him that there would be some betrayal
some misrepresentation of the truth and
that's what's interesting is so like the
whole time he's making all these really
bold choices you think he's kind of this
glib sarcastic professor but um what
he's really doing is he's trying to
unearth truth and he's trying like he's
literally putting his body under all
this brutality because he wants to the
truth to be revealed and that's you know
and every single choice you know that
because every single choice whether he
admits it or not has led toward him
exposing the truth for what it is
so which is better subtext or context
because we know the less you sort of
tell it's like saying which is better
the trigger or the bullet okay all right
okay so maybe which which is the best to
focus on maybe I'm misunderstanding some
of what what because text I get subtext
yeah it makes sense when you said you
took you went to take the drink well
then I can infer that maybe you're
thirsty or maybe you're using it as a
buffer yes subtext is an expression of
the desire okay right and the text is
it's only one means of expressing that
desire sure instead of saying I'm
thirsty and then you but by doing it
it's much more believable or I realize
that you're needing that glass for some
reason but then the context I think is
where I'm like just trying to figure
that out a little bit more so the
context would be okay so for example
[Music]
okay take a simple line go ahead drink
it
right so go ahead drink it is the text
okay we can add different subtext to it
so if I say go ahead drink it there's a
different subtext I'm sure maybe
threatening you right I say go ahead
drink it right I'm saying I don't really
care what you do if I say go ahead
drink it right I change the text
a little bit but the subtext is totally
different now so that's text than
subtext context is we're sitting in a
bus I'm holding a gun this is a clumsy
way I'm holding a gun and you're holding
poison and I'm holding your child so now
the context is extremely loaded and then
the choice that you're about to make is
implicit and I'm saying if you don't
drink it I'm gonna shoot your baby so I
say go ahead drink it see the context he
has this story
the context is a situation you're
dealing with
we can come up with a much better that's
just that comes you know kinda makes but
the idea is that basically like the text
is the ironically because writers tend
to overemphasize dialogues so much the
text tends to get too much importance
the most important stuff is the context
and the subtext because the subtext is
the intention the context is the
conflict that you're dealing with the
situation you're trying to deal with so
if we're in space and we're flying
toward the moon and we know that that's
gravity I don't know as we go if we're
flying toward the moon and we know that
this is that the only thing that's going
to save us is this little serum and it
could either boil our blood or it might
save our lives and we've just given up
and we've been through this whole
journey and we're about to open the
hatch and I say go ahead drink it then
we open the hatch it totally changes the
whole context so that the context is
about the situation you're dealing with
subtext is intention text is just the
artifacts it's one expression of that
desire you would reference the movie
thank you for smoking um in at least one
of your videos forgive me I haven't seen
it but I want to make a point to see it
and I've heard from many people actually
it looked amazing yeah and there were so
many he's so charismatic in it you know
yeah exactly and how he said he has sort
of this BA and what was it what was his
exact same public relations okay
Oh BA yes yeah right and he's
the guy that can talk the girl into
anything kind of thing yeah and so what
what what in that movie how would you
break down the text the subtext in the
context and how much do you think that
relates to the entertainment business in
the sense that they're trying to make it
seem that smoking is okay they're
they're trying to portray that it's
actually okay that see what I think is
interesting I mean ultimately that's
what I love that movie because it's a
polemic it's it's presented as morally
it's it's about moral ambiguity you know
it
there's this larger theme which is
basically saying like culture this is
this is a really complex breakdown it's
a complex movement I love it
it's one of my favorites but at its core
it's it's it's about this guy who's
trying to sell smoking but what he's
really trying to do I mean it's it's an
exercise in rhetoric but what he's
really trying to do is say I don't want
people to determine my life for me I
wanted to take control of my own life
and I would get to decide if I want
throat cancer or not which is why at the
very end you're like if my kid wants to
smoke I'm gonna light it up for him
because it's not really about him saying
like it's okay to smoke what he's really
the whole story is this journey of him
facing these you know largely it's one
of the things that's really close to me
which is large tribal groups trying to
impose their values on individuals and
his individuality coming back and saying
no you I'm gonna do what I want to
do and you're kind of a villain for
trying to impose that on other people
and I and it doesn't in such a clever
polemic way and smoking is really just a
pretext that gets us into it because
it's something that you know most people
largely condemn I don't smoke and it's
not it's not healthy but at the same
time who are you to decide that for
other people and that's what that movie
is asking about but from from a great
rhetorical position you know so would
you say in some sense there's themes in
terms of story the entertainment
industry and how we view what's
acceptable to watch I think like what
Rob Lowe plays the studio executive he's
like pitching up site yeah I think
that's suddenly he's like he names to me
like yes how he sees the world is just
yeah what what you know blockbuster is a
sort of I don't know I've been thinking
about like especially the entertainment
industry and like a lot of a lot of
people like especially on your channel
of the interviews you guys are doing
lots of discussion about you know what
are the best rules for survival in the
entertainment industry and for me
there's a metaphor that just kind of
describes it simply which is that the
entertainment industry
is like a harbor and we have a
constantly shifting tide the water is
going up and down and that tide is the
amount of tension that people are
willing to pay to things now the
industry does the best they can and
we're talking by industry specifically
we're talking about studios distribute
distributors production companies
they're trying to understand which way
the water is going where it's moving and
most of the time like you know as a
writer you're trying to swim in these
choppy seas because you're you you've
built your craft and you're trying to
dock in the harbor now the studios I
have these docks and they're through the
harbor right and because the water is
constantly shifting the best you can do
is make your craft is adaptable to
whatever the needs of the harbor are so
they're they're looking for whatever is
going to draw in the water as much as
possible this metaphor might break down
a little bit if we could take specific
but um but the idea is basically
everybody has to adapt to the shifting
tide then the studios especially they
have the most at stake
so they're looking for stories or
writers crafts persons that have built
crafts that are adaptable to the
shifting tides and you know there's some
studios that have built these massive
mega harbors and your little dinghy
comes up and it's just gonna get beat up
against the water because it'll be
swallowed up because it because the
waters changing so much now especially
with the changing of like streaming and
distribution models are radically
shifting and indie film is shifting and
you know people are making movies for
less than a million dollars the harbor
is dramatically different than it was
five years ago ten years ago
so when it comes to the industry all
you're trying to do is find your path in
the best thing you can do is focus on
developing your craft as much as
possible making as adaptable as possible
which is really just the process of
being able to delve into your metaphors
and really work on being able to tell
the stories that are compelling to other
people and that's that's a no one has
the right answer to that we're all just
figuring that out
it's interesting the other day I went to
uh I went to this bookstore this is cool
experience I had yesterday there's one
actually left I know right there's this
little independent used bookstore
beautiful is over in Atwater Village and
I walked in and I saw these beautiful
typewriters and these Remington's that
were reconstructed and painted and
beautiful and I was drawn into it and
there was this woman there that was she
was writing on it I was like these are
beautiful I wanted to buy one but I was
checking it out - goes oh these are my
my typewriters like oh are they on
exhibit she goes yeah they're uh exhibit
and she said I'm actually a poet I'm
doing a kind of a exhibit and I'm like
what kind of poet are you in she goes
well I do this thing where I look into
your eyes you can tell me a word or a
theme or something and tell me something
that's relevant to you and then I'll
write a poem for you
and you can just pay me whatever you
think it's worth I was like that's
amazing I have to do this yeah it was
very cool so there was this phrase that
was going through my head earlier in the
day the outrunning ghosts it's just an
interesting idea and so I mentioned that
and she she looked at me for a little
bit and I could see the wheels turning
and there's this kind of unique
connection and then she turns around
it's a small slip of paper into the the
Remington and she starts typing and she
starts out with the first runnin ghosts
of love she wrote and then she started
braiding
this poem I just flowed out of her and
it like she almost ran out of space and
she says that rarely happens because
something connected and I just worked
she pulled it out and she said can I
read it to you I was like yes of course
it's even better so she read it to me
and I was surprised that genuinely moved
me and I'm I love poetry most poetry's
awful and so I'm a little skeptical when
it comes to poetry but I wanted to hear
it and she came from such an emotionally
open place when she wrote about it so
she started writing this thing that
genuinely moved me and you know my eyes
teared up and she realized and she got
emotional from it as well and what was
what was amazing was that she was
actually tapping into something that was
deeply relevant to me personally and I
think that right there is the core of
great writing which is that she opened
herself up emotionally and she delved
into her own subconscious in a way that
she was able to extract this metaphors
that resonated with me in a very very
deep way we don't know each other at all
her name is Jacqueline Susskind and I
just remember because it she assigned it
and put her name at the bottom of the
poem and it was this beautiful
experience where just by engaging the
metaphors that were relevant to her she
spoke to something that I needed to
learn an experience and that to me is at
the core of what what it means to be a
writer it's at the core would it mean to
be an artist to engage those metaphors
and so what we're trying to do as
writers screenwriters novelists
storytellers short stories whatever
we're trying to delve into that
meaningful place that vulnerable place
and in some way diagnose or identify or
even just express some conflict through
the metaphors we're engaging and that's
where we find the meaning
the anatomy of chaos this I mean so do
you think she's like an empathic poet is
that definitely she was showing pure
empathy um I don't like I'm skeptical
when it comes to you know supernatural
things and things like that but um
whatever whatever metaphor she was
dealing with or that she was drawing on
spoke directly to me in a really
beautiful way and and I think great
writers can do that I think very you
know and when I say great writers I mean
I think everybody should be writing it
makes us all better so like Vonnegut
says go write a poem it'll make you a
better person but great writers are able
to tap into that that subconscious in
such a way that they'll speak to a human
experience that connects to all of us
interesting you said ghosts cuz I just
finished every love story is a ghost
story I think about David Foster Wallace
oh so it's about his life I couldn't
read the end breaks my heart it's too
sad and I started to get angry in
sometimes because he was so talented
yeah and and I felt like it was it was
such a waste and I was very upset and I
couldn't read the end but I read the
beginning in the middle and it's just an
interesting concept of ghosts as well
because because in some sense is that
all we're seeking is is this like just
how she wrote this poem just like this
empathic experience through what we what
we watched what we read are we looking
for what we're watching to basically
tell us about ourselves yeah and so I
was just wondering and you brought up
the ghosts so that was just interesting
because I had just finished that but
yeah yeah that's beautiful yeah David
Foster Wallace yeah with your videos I
again I keep going back to these videos
but they are amazing and I see that you
have almost all positive feedback how
does that make you feel it feels great I
mean make you want to keep going with it
or yeah like people are really generous
with the compliments it's been
very nice originally I was saying things
that I thought people would find
provocative I thought people are gonna
be angry at the way I defined act or
impetus and just because I'm
ridiculously pedantic and stuff about
that but um it's it's motivating because
you know because people want like it
actually helps them in their process and
that's you know it just feels good
I recently released this one video that
I worked for a long time on did you see
the one about religion and story I I saw
some of it I noticed he got strong
reactions yeah and I was curious about
that forgive me I didn't watch that one
no that's okay yeah it's it's it's the
longest one it's 35 minutes and it's
probably one of the more controversial
ones just because I'm making very bold
claims about the the nature and
definition of religion but the cool
thing is is it's been getting some
really interesting attention from I was
contacted I had sent it to David Sloan
Wilson who is the president of the
evolution Institute and he he contacted
me and he's like this is some really
interesting work I think we should
submit this for peer review and what I'd
like to talk to you about some of your
ideas and how you think this is and
informing the conversation so right now
there's you know I I made a few very
bold I claims about what the nature of
religion basically that I define
religion in very broad but specific
terms which is that it's it's a strategy
for survival that informs the narratives
we tell ourselves and the consequence of
that is that it draws people together
and it's and ultimately it's defined by
those those values of the sacred and the
profane so the it this is a conversation
I've been fascinated by this you know a
lot of the secular movements and like
the culture wars going on between you
know for example religion and atheism
and and then looking at like other other
aspects of culture war of the culture
wars there going on
and I think at the core of it it is if
we're able to be honest about the way we
interpret information the way we develop
our loyalties we'll actually be able to
critically evaluate our sacred totems
are our metaphors and then begin to
deconstruct whether those metaphors are
accurate to reality I think ultimately
if we look at the paradigm of health
health is just about being able to
respond proportionately to threats and
opportunities so I think if we can begin
to look at religion not as just this
kind of bizarre a lot of metaphors is
that it's a kind of a virus that
overtakes the mind but instead it's the
way we develop value systems through
metaphors and you know being someone
who's deeply invested in story and the
way we develop narratives to develop
value systems I think we we need to
understand that process and that's why
I'm so specific and trying to understand
like what art is versus science and how
those two relate because we can't have
one without the other
I mean as soon as we try to represent
something it's a form of art as soon as
it becomes an emotional experience then
that informs our values so so it's it's
really exciting it's been an honor just
to start talking with with David and I'm
really curious to see what it comes up
with because it's it's a controversial
it's controversial claims but I think
it's the conversation that needs to
happen and that's what I'm really
interested in and engaging Plus you know
I have a lot to say I have a lot of
things I care about a lot of things I'm
passionate about and all of that goes
into my writing all that goes into the
stories you know it's interesting that
we have to have this like subcategory or
whatever for faith-based scripts mmm I
don't know I just find that interesting
I mean you know if you look at it from
like a you know a scale or a line and
you have on one end a cult and then on
the other end would just be an openness
to something that's greater than
ourselves you know and then we could
just kind of go in the middle but it
just seems like a lot of that can
he talks about even if it's not if it's
like Nam nondenominational like it just
it seems like no one can really have
that in a screenplay without it being
okay well this is a faith-based script
it's got to be that category you know I
mean ultimately the that comes on to
distribution and marketing you know and
most of distribution of marketing is
about responding to kind of axiomatic
ideas connotative beliefs of what most
people think of something like when you
say faith-based you know there's a lot
of argument about like belief versus
knowledge and how some people don't
believe anything but the truth of it is
is everybody has belief belief is just
when you internalized information and
accept it is true but you know when you
say something is faith-based you know
that's it those are that's jargon that
is designed to gear toward a very
specific genre and I don't know some
someone that has you know being someone
that has a kind of a skeptical view
toward a lot of traditional narratives
I'm still fascinated by it you know
being raised religious I was fascinated
by all the metaphors but I think that
ultimately helped me to begin to engage
story on a different level looking at
how those metaphors exists how they work
and how we internalize them we talk
about check-offs gun so basically the
Chekhov's gun is that the axiom is if
there's a gun on the wall and you
mention it you have to use it if the gun
doesn't go off then you've set up an
expectation that you didn't deliver on
and it's a good principle and again it's
one of those principles where it's like
generally speaking you want to obey it
but again look at No Country for Old Men
they Llewellyn Moss is a loaded gun on
the wall and in the end he fails and it
doesn't we don't get what we expected
but it meant something to the story so
it's like every principle it
it helps us to understand like that the
general principle is that if you're
going to talk about something no detail
in any store should ever be wasted your
especially with screenwriting you have
you want to be as sparse as possible you
want to be as specific as possible so
when you're writing something you're not
just throwing stuff out there it all has
to be you should regard every single
word as a kind of setup that you now
have a debt to resolve but that said if
you are going to break that rule have a
really good reason for it
no country for old men is the perfect
reason because it bill directly
contributed to the interpretation of the
theme so even like if you just want to
paint you know it like in novels hmm I
think are we much more apt to someone an
author is gonna paint a world and maybe
add little details but in a screenplay
no you're saying don't don't do too much
of that world because it's it's just I
would say using to a novel writing oh
really
yeah because I mean it really comes down
to you know the voice the language and a
lot of the times when you're setting
something up you're trying to plant
seeds of something that you don't want
the kit the audience to be paying
attention to because later it pays off
and comes through and you're like oh I
didn't even see that coming but if you
didn't set it up beforehand then it
feels like a cheat when it's suddenly
introduced it really just comes down to
really knowing the craft it's super
specific to the needs of your story and
a lot of that will depend on you know
get in front of other people see if it
feels like a cheap see if it feels like
you're setting something up sometimes if
you say you know the laser gun sitting
on the table you're gonna be like wait
laser gun are we in the future you know
and those are things you need to pay
attention to and a lot of that is you
know fine-tooth comb in your script and
getting other people to read it and
gauging their expectations and getting
getting as much feedback as you can you
talked earlier about adapting your
videos into a book but you also have a
novel that she wrote yeah that has to do
with the entertainment industry yeah
and religion it's got a lot of just
interesting stuff and you made a book
trailer yeah which I watched was that
something that someone advised you to do
or you knew all along because you're so
visual as well that you wanted to it's a
cool trailer by the way thank you I
appreciate that I had a lot of fun with
it
yeah I mean it is something like you
know in researching releasing a book
independently I was looking at
everything you know they're like you got
to do a book trailer you should start
doing videos that engage an audience and
all of these things anatomy of chaos
this book trailer all these things are
kind of my attempt at doing these things
and so with with the the trailer I
wanted to do a scene like most trailers
kind of have these light you know in a
world with it and then it's like these
flowing like kind of animated titles or
pictures or montage which some of them
are cool there's a few that are done
well but I'm like so the novel I had
originally written as a season as a
miniseries and here's the quick pitch
basically a reality show producer takes
a hipster from Silver Lake and through a
bunch of trickery and Industrial Light
and Magic
creates a profit and online profit he
says this is going to be a new religion
so using like all this tricks in the
entertainment industry and the reality
shows he's like I'm gonna make this a
new religion the thing that is is it
takes off and it turns into a legitimate
religion a kind of a cult a weird
religion and along the way the Prophet
begins to believe or may actually be an
actual prophet and certain things start
to happen we're always with the main
characters names Tommy Knox reality show
producer he's cynical skeptical
sarcastic glib he's hilarious character
and and the whole story is these is
these two characters one this cynical
sarcastic person and one a completely
sincere devout person and the the
incredible conflict that they come to it
at the core of it I was really
fascinated by the idea of what if there
is this religious movement that took the
world by storm but it was invented by a
cynical which i think is so
funny and interesting and then the
places that it goes is this really dark
interesting polemic that I wanted to
tell
so I structured it in such a way like
originally I can see that as a feature
years ago the more I explored it the
more I was like there's so much good
interesting stuff here with the
characters with entertainment and
religion and the overlap of the two it
turned into I want to do a miniseries
out of this so I wrote the novel so each
chapter is like a an episode and you
know and so it's 24 chapters will be 24
episodes and I've adapted a pilot that
you know we're also I'm talking to a few
different producers that they're they're
taking some interest in and but I had
adapted the novel so it reads like an
HBO series or a Netflix series and it's
it's hilarious it's a comedy it's
completely different from cereal but I'd
like to think that it has the same level
of sophistication and and some of the
characters and it's a lot of the complex
characters that are engaging in the
story
so yeah it took you four months to write
yes how many pages it's a hundred or
pages I don't know it's a hundred eighty
thousand words so it depends I however
reformat it which is the average first
novel you want it to be around between
ninety to a hundred thousand words
mine's almost twice that because of what
I wanted to do I wanted to have first of
all it's it's a story that's been in me
it's the issues that I care deeply about
entertainment art religiosity and the
way we build metaphors as groups of
people it's really interesting to me and
there was so much interesting fodder and
places that it could go that I really
wanted to take the time and I'm
self-publishing it so you know I hired
some editors to to
and I'm really proud of it I think it's
great the the pilots getting really good
attention and now we have a complete
template for a whole miniseries for it
but yeah it is it is something that's
it's a meaty tome but it reads very
sparse very smooth so it's available now
on Amazon it is available now in fact
we're we're looking at it having
adapting it to audiobook oh wow yeah
which is great I'm really excited about
that that we don't have an official
announcement like when it's gonna be
coming out but the book right now is
available you can buy either ebook or
print as well and the cover is really
cool you yeah I painted it I designed it
and painted it so yeah that's that's a
good example of some of the painting I
do I have a classical background in
classical artworks I painted and I used
to teach oil painting at CalArts I lived
in Mexico for a few years and painting
murals and made a few tricks or made a
Trek to Italy and all that stuff so so
yeah that's a huge part of what's
interesting to me about it I did
publishers appreciate your artwork some
of them I've been approached by a couple
different publishers and you know each
publisher wants to put their brand in
their approach to it and yeah overall
I've had a really good response my
original idea was to publish the the
novel independently largely to get it to
it adapted to television I I do think
it's a strong book that stands on its
own I think it's I think it's
entertaining but you know I'm - my own
horn but but I've been getting great
reaction from it have you approached any
bookstores to try to get I mean I did
the few that are left to try to get it
on the shelves I'll occasionally do
signings and things like that
oh but yeah and I you know try to make
it interesting and exciting and stuff
but honestly it's largely an online
thing like most of most of the book
sales especially now are largely online
and so I I tend and this is part of my
problem I tend to focus more on just the
writing
and right now with the stuff I'm
developing and the attention we're
getting with with the stuff that some of
the stuff we're shopping around that's
kind of my main boilerplate but profit
margin is you know we're we're keeping
that going we're keeping that flame laid
what do people ask you at these signings
I always think that it's such as
interesting it's kind of just like this
weird meet and greet and yeah seems like
it could be uncomfortable but it's on at
the same time I like meeting people I
mean I'm a social person so I enjoy it
yeah I've had a few people that are what
are they ask you I don't know maybe they
ask you for your phone number or
something else there's that there's uh
okay so profit margin I will give this
away there's a secret narrative and some
people have tapped into that and there's
certain clues that I've written along
the way if you if you read it and you
come to the end there's a there's two
potential ways of interpreting the
ending and not to give too much away but
a lot of people ask me questions about
like so this character Michelangelo
that's a clue right there if you start
to unravel were like what these
characters want what they're doing and
what they mean to the story you can
actually start to see what the secret
narrative is so there's two different
ways of interpreting the same book so a
lot of it is like some people are
arguing about like what what the story
actually means which is great because
that's what I wanted it to be a polemic
I wanted it to be a conversation starter
this is a story within a story or are
you leaving clues I'm leaving clues so
basically it's by double narrative I
mean you're you're ideally you're
reading it trying to figure how to say
this without giving away too much you're
reading it in such a way that you're
you're interpreting it as okay so for
example there are some miracles that
happen and as you're reading it some
people read it they're like wow these
miracles are amazing and the other
people are reading it saying oh these
are productions this is Tommy Knox
working his productions and he's working
behind the scenes to make this look
like a miracle and so then the question
becomes is this guy is the character he
creates is he your prophet or not and
the answer to that question is within
the hidden narrative and I don't want to
give that away okay
which is why the book is called profit
margin so with profit margin did you do
the same thing with the screenwriting
and you added the dialogue later I'm
sure there's heavy dialogue and there is
nothing yeah I mean it's been really
interesting adapting it so years ago I
had written a feature version of it and
then when I went back to revisit it it
was like there's so much here I'm gonna
write I'm literally just gonna write the
entire season as a novel
so then after writing the entire novel I
was like I'm gonna go back and just
adapt the pilot I'd love that I'm really
proud of the pilot and I've gotten
really good responses from it but in
doing that the pilot has a very
different function than for example like
a first chapter in a novel so like for
example there were certain characters I
needed to flush out to kind of imply
that this is gonna be a journey of
several different characters the novel
was written largely from just the
perspective of Tommy Knox for the pilot
we want to see that there's some other
characters that have really strong
narrative so I adapted some scenes that
are in the pilot that are not in the
novel and that's largely - - like with a
pilot you want to set up an engine that
these characters will will you want to
get a strong sense of the kind of
conflicts and kind of character and
emotional dynamics you're going to be
dealing with in a pilot that will extend
itself through the whole season and so a
lot of a lot of that like a novel you
have time to kind of build and explore
and weave things and with with the pilot
and to be very concise very specific do
a lot of trimming killing a lot of
darlings which you know so but the
dialogue the nice thing is is like I
like this is about a slick producer he's
good with sales he's very sarcastic
charismatic
so he's fun to write his dialogue is so
much fun to write so a lot of it was
taken straight from the book and and
then you know from there I just kind of
had to adapt it to the needs of the
pilot you know it's like I would have a
scene that would go on for you know five
10 pages in a novel and I'd have to trim
it down to half a page or two pages and
that's you know that's that's what the
the needs for the for the format are
where did you find these editors did you
find them online and you just looked
yeah I talked to other novelists and
other writers that I trust and checked
references and yeah and it's it's just
the process of like what I would I would
do like a there's some services where
you can sign up and you'll ask for
petitions for editors and I think I had
like something like 80 different editors
that we're interested in the project and
then from there I just had him just do a
quick edit of just like the ten page
sequence and just to see what their
notes were and then from there I boiled
it down to three editors and then I got
in the phone they had a discussion about
like what I intended to do and what
their experience was and what their
expectations were and yeah it was it was
a it was a cool process so are they
looking at it not just for you know
punctuation and grammar things like that
but also the structure and and how it
reads yeah so what I did I went for the
full package so I the copy editors which
are looking at the punctuation making
sure that you know send structure and
all that stuff is good
and then there's content editors and the
content editors I went with a content
editor first because you want to those
are the ones that are interested in
structure character that they need to be
very familiar with with how story works
and it's that second pair of eyes I mean
a good editor is invaluable
especially for someone like me who loves
to just write and loves to go in the
deep end and I can just spend all day
swim in the deep end I need someone to
say all right it's time to get out of
the water so yeah so a content editor
what really helps with with making sure
that all of the story dynamics are work
that like you know those things we
talked about that my intention was to do
this I just need to make sure it's
coming across and yeah I found a great
content editor and then after that I
hired a copy editor to just go through
and make sure all the commas are in the
right place and no books perfect and
every time I read it I still find one or
two mistakes but or maybe probably more
than one or two but um but yeah it's I'm
really proud of it I think it's a it's a
fun read and it reads really smooth
anything it's hilarious well it's been
such a dream of so many people I feel
like not so much of this generation but
of you know Generation X and before to
write this great American novel you know
and a lot of that seems to be I guess
it's not going away but it seems like
less and less because now everybody who
wants to be a youtuber or whatever sort
of live this you know influencer
lifestyle and and some of that feels
like it's gone away a little no I don't
mix at all I think I think
story's never been more powerful like I
mean there's definitely like you know
they talked about the democratization of
distribution of publishing of writing
and producing and making films and
everything so I more people are writing
more people are publishing putting their
stuff out there it also means that you
have a lot more maybe lower quality
stuff some writers they're their main
goal is to put out as much as they can
without necessarily spending as much
time on the quality which is a strategy
for me I'm you know I want to make it as
good as I possibly can so I spent I mean
I wrote it quickly in four months but
that four months was the product of ten
years of preparation beforehand so you
know I wrote in four months and then
spent the next year working with the
editor getting it to a place where we
both felt like it was ready to publish
so it's I mean there's so many writers
and now this is you know like youtubers
and things like that that's a new it's a
newer phenomenon
but it's great because it's more voices
and I still believe that you know people
that are putting out good content
attract the kind of attention that and
their that merits it you know it's it's
the cream always rises to the top and
you know it probably means that there's
like a higher ratio of just total
that's out there but you know but
ultimately it's the good stuff still
comes through and you know it can happen
naturally or virally I know a
distributors are working really hard at
trying to market stuff but you know if
it's it's and if it's not then
it gets some attention when you finished
profit margin did you feel almost sad
did you feel a depression like a
postpartum depression we were talking
about yeah like yeah your baby's out
there and graduated and well the first
thing that happened is I hated
it because I finished it and I was like
I just wasted I've been I love this
story for so long I finished it and then
I was like that's all it was it's
something personal every project as soon
as I finish it I got to get away from it
because I'm like sick of it right and I
think like oh that's all it was because
it's you know in your mind you build it
up and it's gonna do all these different
things
so the I did you know the right thing is
I got away from it and I just put it
away and then a couple months later I
went back and I'm like alright you're a
little bit fresh now reread it there's a
lot of good stuff and so you know
started the rewrites and stuff like that
and then took it through a few different
rewrites and then got it to the editor
shortly after that but yeah like you
know you you begin to develop a
relationship with the characters and the
more effort and energy you put into the
story the more it means to you so you
know like Tommy Knox he's a fun
character right and nava who's the
profit in the character he's really
interesting and matic character
there's the whole dynamic the world is
fun to write but that's true with every
every story I write when I'm done with
it it's I put it away and they're just
kind of this
I don't know but I mean at the same time
I I tend to be juggling a lot of
projects so I'll put one away hate that
project and then fall in love with this
new project and it's you know it's like
that one cat's cradle Kurt Vonnegut book
where the the scientist is like he just
gets distracted by turtles and like the
Defense Department is like we really
need him to work on this bomb again and
he's like yeah but he's trying to figure
out what the nature of turtles are you
know it's like you I'm endlessly seeking
out new fascination and they but that's
just how my mind works I'm constantly
interested in new ideas and then I'm
interested in taking those ideas and
making them building emotional
narratives around them
in what ways can a screenwriter ruin a
scene it's almost easier to ask which
way they can fix it because there's so
many ways to ruin it I mean there's lots
of ways to do something badly you know
some of the most typical ways are just
you know exposition just using like
straight I'm going to explain exactly
what I want
often if the dialogue dialogue is if the
dialogue is directly proportionate to
the desires like somebody that walks
around and says I want this glass of
water I want to shake your hand
I want you know they're when their
action is directly proportionate to what
they're saying it gets it tends to get
bad it tends to get you're not you're
not revealing anything about the
character and you're not exposing and
you're not emotionally engaging although
there was a really interesting exception
to that like did you see the killing of
a sacred deer no I wanted to I was
watching the trailer and and I think I
missed the window at the Laemmle and I
wanted to see it it's so I loved it I
mean it looks like filmmaker but he did
this he did this thing where he's
breaking all the rules and there's no
rules whatever it but um but you know
this assumption of like having
characters say exactly what they want
saying exactly what's on their mind
and delivering it in this kind of
deadpan way and it does it in such a way
that's incredibly intriguing and I still
can't wrap my brain around I'm still
kind of trying to understand why it was
so effective but I couldn't take my eyes
off of it like it's it's you know Colin
Farrell walking around with this kid
talking about watches and the importance
of just you know this this I think I
should get a new wristband and it's
important and there's they're very
matter-of-fact and it feels just left of
normal conversation like it doesn't it
feels very contrived and stilted and
it's for some reason you just slowly get
drawn into this kind of rhythm and
cadence and then before you know it
you're like oh these people are they're
not talking about their watches they're
talking about what these what their
relationships actually mean to each
other and it's it's so well done I loved
it I really want to see that yeah it's
really darkly funny like there are a few
movies this last year that where they
felt like these kind of dark dramas but
they were so funny they were written in
this great absurdist way like mother i
thought mother was hilarious good to see
that looks really intriguing because you
couldn't really figure out from the
trailer what it was about it wasn't
really clear yeah I'm actually planning
on doing a video where I want to talk
about allegory and I think mother is
much more interesting than a lot of
people are giving it credit for it just
because of it's cool to see a filmmaker
who's deliberately engaging allegory and
allegorical tropes in a way the very few
are so it's and it will be fun I don't
put that be forthcoming must be a tease
I'm not sure if this relates to contrast
but to say that the audience loves
contrast I think you talked about in one
of your videos if a character comes in
angry then they need to leave with some
resolve or or happy something but if
they come in happy then they need to
leave the scene angry there needs to be
some kind of a contrast yeah that's
that's a principle I learned from you
know just reading Robert McKee basically
that the idea is that a scene turns on
the emotional state of the character or
characters
and basically the idea is that by
contrast the whole point of stories to
get us to engage emotionally so what
when we're tracking something you know
the logic should be as it should be as
logical as it needs to be so that we can
emotionally invest in something so
something needs to be logical if it
within the confines of the world just
enough so that we can care about what
the care because what we really are
interested in is what is the emotional
state of these characters so and the
best way to know if a scene is turned is
if the character comes in with this you
know positive emotion they experience
some conflict and the results
causes a shift if they come in happy and
they leave happy
generally speaking nothing significant
has happened and so what we're what
we're looking for when we're structuring
our scenes or what I'm looking for when
I'm structure my scenes is some sort of
emotionally significant experience that
changes the way they're seeing their
situation and then from there using
their strategy they adapt to two new
conflicts is that the one where you used
Glengarry Glen Ross I think you use some
of that maybe it wasn't that one you
know mammoth screed is what does the
character want why now and what happens
if they don't get it you know so it's
asking those three questions which firm
form a kind of litmus tests to whether
the scene is worth it and then from
there you know taking McKee's principle
of of turning the scene from a positive
to a negative or negative to a positive
and the idea of contrast is basically
what I was trying to say is that we want
to pace out of film and it shouldn't be
just ridiculous jumps and contrasts if
she comes in like if a main character
comes in and she's just exploding with
joy and then hits the depths of sorrow
that's melodrama and we begin to
disengage or just you know I mean
there's plenty of exceptions to this but
but ultimately what we're looking for is
a kind of journey which means we're
we're we're following the emotional
journey that they're going through with
ups and downs and usually some shifts
and then sometimes it drops out from
under you so a lot of that is about
understanding the way you can pace out
and establish a rhythm of different
scenes and you start to develop certain
stakes and then you drop it and raise
the stakes and things like that so it's
all about playing with the expectations
and getting the audience to guess what's
gonna happen next so are those the three
questions sometimes you'll ask with your
care avy even supporting characters and
not just the protagonist or the
antagonist but just some of the
supporting ones yeah so a lot of thing
about about structure especially is
largely to do with rewriting although
that does inform outlining as well
that's all the principles inform each
other a lot of the story structure
theory like for example especially like
scene dynamics that that video was
largely due to kind of like almost like
checklist of once you've already written
a scene these are some ways to know if
it's working or not so I took Mamet's
Mamet's Creed and I took Robert maki's
principle of like turning from the
emotions up to positive and negative and
vice versa and then I came up with a
list of like essential scene dynamics
and a lot of that just it's kind of like
a checklist of something that I'll be
reading something old I'll make sure
that each scene that I write has these
elements and if they don't have the
elements then it's then usually I can
diagnose exactly what's what's wrong
with it what's not working with it
there's certain films that you've come
to later in life like you watched it the
first time I know we talked about how
when I first came to LA that Glengarry
Glen Ross was just the talk of the town
and then I couldn't appreciate it at
that age but then I watched it later and
I just saw how brilliant it was yes
certain films that first time you saw
them and then you realize like how
incredible something was later okay
a Clockwork Orange I saw that when I was
maybe 13 years old and I couldn't finish
it I was so bothered by it it made me
angry it made me upset there was that
scene that horrible scene where they
break into that family's house and it's
and it made me it just bothered me and
people were always talking about how
brilliant it was and I was just genius
film and I couldn't finish it and then
years later when I was at film school I
watched it and I was like oh it was
because I was so emotionally impacted
that that showed the power of the film I
just wasn't at a place level of maturity
where I could kind of appreciate it for
the art that it was and now I think it's
it's brilliant it's still brutal but to
try and understand like what Kubrick was
doing like this there was just endless
amounts of lessons and it's just a
brilliant piece of film but there's
there's a ton of films like that
um Reservoir Dogs first that was another
one I stopped it I stopped it right when
he was torturing the cop I couldn't take
it I was just like this is too much this
is too dark and then of course right
after that scene there's the big reveal
no spoilers but there's the big reveal
so I started watching that again when I
was like 14 years old I'm like this is
just too dark it's too brutal and years
later I watched the entire thing I'm
like oh there's so much more to it so
though having those few experiences was
like okay I need to sit through a film
and let the let let the filmmaker take
me on the journey you know it's and
there's you know and there's movies like
um I was the Antichrist then I wanted to
get out of that film because it was so
brutal it's still one of the most
horrifying movies I've ever seen
but you see that one
I'm thinking of platoon I think I saw
that with a bunch of people and it was
just I couldn't wait for it to I was too
brutal for me yeah by that I mean now
it's I mean now I'm just like I try to
like just be open to it I still don't
like you know torture porn is doesn't
doesn't do much work ironically because
this you know I'm working on a show that
has elements of well it's largely
psychological horror but it does like
there would be some some people would
over have some overlap with like some
torture scenes but ultimately it's it's
about how this is impacting them
emotionally but yeah a lot of the is
about you know you don't have to sit and
sit through anything you don't have to
go experience art it's just the more you
do the more rewarding it is to you I
know you're a fan of Joseph Campbell the
hero's journey yeah and most people are
I there's not really any criticism of
yes sir
well I think like I learned so much from
Joseph Campbell I like I discovered him
pretty young I was like maybe 16 or 17
when I started reading him and I was you
know amazed by it and of course the
thing that was nice about him was he was
kind of a foray into young and like you
know the theory of archetypes and things
like that so it was you know it's it
well well Campbell's dense you know it's
it's a totally different thing to delve
into Jung and Freud and all those things
and what a part of the issue like I know
that like for example the hero and the
hero's journey and people regard the
hero is like one of the the central
architects are the character but a this
I think
Joseph Campbell illuminated certain
insights in this story that I that were
incredibly helpful but I don't think
it's enough of a complete theory and I
plan on doing a video about this later
to kind of get more specific but just to
give a teaser I mean ultimately you know
when we look at a hero here is a very
specific it's a specific kind of
character that's why I tend to refer to
things as a protagonist versus a hero a
hero's is someone that
exhibits certain virtues and values that
are considered and ideal and usually the
story is about them testing their mettle
but a story can be so much more than
just a kind of vulgar propaganda on on
exhibiting ideal virtues and that's why
I like the hero's journey I think is
brilliant it's fantastic one thing that
I liked about Joseph Campbell was that
he was exploring the way the
universality of certain story structures
but I don't think it's enough of a
complete paradigm because when we look
at why we tell stories it it doesn't
quite account for the initiation of the
tribe or into the tribe and that's
that's what I think is that's something
that's very fascinating to me is that
like my next video is about tribalism
actually I'm in the process of talking
about tribalism I'd set up the
relationship between a really religion
and story in one video and I'm going to
tie into tribalism and I'm defining
tribalism in a very specific way we're
gonna go into the kind of biological
imperatives that inform tribalism but
basically I and this little teaser but
um I find groups there are different
groups of people that define themselves
according to what their objectives are
so for example a community is a group of
people with a common interests a
movement is a group of people with a
common cause a tribe is a group of
people with a common enemy hmm so and
they have very very different ways of
functioning if you have an enemy that
creates a kind of usually creates a kind
of loyalty becomes very important
it's a virtues it's a virtue within a
tribe within a community of broad open
interests you don't necessarily need
loyalty in order to function you can
just have voluntary interaction
with tribalism because it defines itself
primarily by its enemy and it presents
presents it as a threat and therefore
hierarchy becomes very important and a
lot of stories throughout most of
history most of the history of humanity
were designed to help create those
hierarchies so because most tribes were
surviving in the context of a lot of a
lot of constant threat perpetual threat
which means they had to live in very
rigid communities or really rigid groups
of people so the narratives and the
stories they would tell were always
about hero structures they were there
designed to help people incorporate
these values and these virtues as vital
to survival and so because of that the
this hero's journey was ultimately a
kind of propaganda because it was
designed to to drive people's behavior
and value system to be subject and loyal
to the tribe and that's why I think
stories that are more engaged in moral
ambiguity have much more interesting
things that to tell because they're not
just interested in imposing or
propagating specific narrow values that
emphasize loyalty but instead will
actually explore the nature of the human
condition and that's what I think is a
much more interesting thing if we can
understand the way that story is a kind
of exploration of values rather than
just a propagation of values then I
think we actually have more meaningful
discourse in an understanding story and
in humanity I think I asked you earlier
if you'd seen the movie margin call and
I just recently saw that one late too I
think it was 2010 or whatever but I
think that's a great when you're talking
about groups of people and some of the
the the rules of sort of the let me try
that again
we talked about the movie margin call
just watched it I think you
- yeah I'm wondering who is the hero in
that film is a Stanley Tucci's character
we'll see that's what I think is so
interesting about it
margin call is a great exploration of
moral ambiguity so it's a perfect
example of breaking this concept of the
hero's journey it's about a phenomena
that happened it's about people who were
who were willing to make certain moral
concessions in order to achieve certain
advantages and in that way we began to
explore this this whole new world like
through margin call we began to explore
this whole world of finance and and
collusion corruption without necessarily
condemning or or dismissing it as just
this I mean yes it's a it's a it's a
disturbing thing that happened but it
explored it in such a way that was
trying to say like we're trying to look
at the psychological mechanisms that
were active to create this situation
because we're still trying to wrap our
head around that recession we're still
trying to wrap our head around like all
the consequences and how we got there
and the whole point of story is really
to help us to build meaning so that we
can avoid falling in those pits and
margin calls a perfect example of
exploring that without trying to impose
virtues but instead engage a deeper
understanding of what were the causes
and that to me is really interesting
storytelling I mean I still enjoy heroes
during stories like you know Star Wars
is like the original three were some of
my favorite movies when I was a kid but
margin call was was designed to be
critical and arrive at a certain
understanding it wasn't trying to say
these are the good guys these are the
bad guys and that's why I think it was a
much more sophisticated interesting
story yeah that was a brilliant film and
it was done I think with very few crew
members and yeah I think I was hearing
that maybe there were so few crew
members that people were when they saw
some of the town
in the film like it was such an open set
that it was hard to keep onlookers away
because there was not it was not a lot
of security which is really such a small
production yeah it's a pretty tained
but with with the so you would say
though that maybe Stanley Tucci's
character and margin call wasn't the
hero but he was a protagonist obviously
yes I mean he was definitely somebody
that represented a certain moral that we
aspired to and it's kind of sick there
is the the kind of implication of like
if we had just had his but I mean he was
somebody that wasn't able to to prevent
it either you know so it's like he's
somebody that's that's behaving nobly
and with integrity in several characters
or but but ultimately it wasn't it
wasn't just this simple this is how to
behave to solve this problem it's an
exploration of like what are the
psychological dynamics which is to me
that's so much more interesting
let's take spotlight for a moment you
saw spotlight okay so who is there a
hero and that is Mark Ruffalo's
character the hero sort of exposing some
of this stuff that's a you bring up
several that's another one that I
wouldn't say is propaganda because it's
not
it wasn't about trying to impose a value
system it's about exploring the causes
and I think a lot of the great stuff is
trying to explore the causes of what how
we get in the situation and spotlight
ultimately that's what was so great
about um what's his name Birdman oh
right how was Michael Keaton yeah that's
what's so great about Michael Keaton's
character was they had that moment where
he was where he realized that he was the
one that closed down the story like he
realized that he was contributing to
some of the cover-up
not because he was deliberately
corrupted or colluding but that's what
the story is about is about the fact
that we're not looking in the right
direction when it comes to certain
things that are harming us and it asks
the question why are we looking past
these things why aren't we seeing these
predatory behaviors for what they are
and that's why I think it's a great
movie because it's it's about how slowly
culture or dilates the spotlight to
focus on the things that we need to and
then the balance becomes you know how do
we focus on it without a witch hunt and
that's that's another interesting theme
all right and then you talked about
tribes and community and so tribe is
something that has a common enemy yeah
right and then community I mean we've
all anybody who has had a corporate job
where you know you have to sort of
there's politics goes unspoken politics
and then there's spoken and and that's
the thing about margin call was that was
presented in a way where a lot of times
we have to look the other way for things
and we don't want to but we know if we
want to keep a job yeah kind of have to
sell out and that's that was so
brilliantly portrayed in that film never
had a Seth Godin book tribe I have not I
think I've watched some videos where
he's talked about it okay but I think
has amazing library of books that he's
written so he's it's interesting because
what he defines his tribe I would define
more as a community hmm largely because
what he's saying is we need tribal
leaders we want you to find people that
like we need people that are passionate
that are interested that are engaged to
take up their mantle and explore things
that they're interested in and that's
good that's all healthy to me it becomes
tribalism when you introduce an enemy
because then immediate because what he's
describing is voluntary interactions of
passionate people and that's a good
healthy thing that's a robust community
but with a tribe it turns into it turns
into this is our enemy right this is how
we're and that's when a lot of the
thinking becomes disproportionate that's
when we begin to interpret everything as
a threat and it's great at creating
loyalties it's a I mean if you look at
the political landscape we're looking at
it was all about people doing everything
they could to portray the person they
disagreed with as an enemy
yeah and therefore we have tribal
loyalties it
it's a great way to like short-circuit
people submitting to or complying with
things that they would never comply with
otherwise so I think ultimately
tribalism has its place like you look at
the military it's a deeply tribal
culture and it should be because it
needs to be able to respond to threats
that's the purpose of it but generally
speaking as as like a nation as a
country tribalism is rarely the right
answer
just because most of the time we don't
have these threats we don't have these
enemies we mostly have causes that we
want to resolve issues that we want to
resolve and collaborate and ideally
mostly we have common interests that we
voluntarily interact with so and that's
something I'm going to be talking about
in my interview and in the next
tribalism video so I don't want to give
too much of a cheap give you a oh my
good company and also to the the the as
you said without getting too deep into
specifics of the political landscape
that it's made some people who weren't
tribal members parts of new tribes yeah
and and and and people that have been
friends for years yeah basically turn on
each other
that's radicalized everybody mmm-hmm
right not everybody I mean I think most
people are like this is just silly it's
just getting ridiculous but but yeah I
mean you know you have these people
behaving radically which creates a lot
of strong emotional reactions and that
strong emotional reaction just breeds
condemnation condemnation breeds fear
and which ultimately breeds loyalty and
separation so you know a big thing that
I'm a big theme that were it works it
goes through almost all of my stories is
this idea of how do groups work and how
do they develop value systems versus the
individual how the individual develops
value systems and so a lot of my stories
are all about a person slowly coming to
realize and this is true from my own
personal life story somebody who's very
much wrapped up in the narratives of a
group becoming aware of how those value
systems have failed them
and then begin to engage the work of
deconstructing that in their own life
and then overcoming it that's that's
something that's probably a big theme in
almost all of all the stories that I
write but I also think it that resonates
with a lot of other people too who is
the author that said men go mad in
crowds forgive me I should know I don't
know it's a great quote though it's a
it's a famous I think I said it I'll
claim it okay that sounds good yeah you
see that or otherwise um men go mad in
crowds
story is the act of dreaming while you
are awake yeah so I think that's at the
core of what the function of dream is
and what this function of story is and
that's why I've repeated it several
times throughout the series and you know
the process of dreaming is the the way
we internalize the information from the
day into our value system so we're all
composed of these sub conscious and
subconscious is constantly absorbing
information now we have to learn to
prioritize that information or we won't
survive we can't even navigate the world
around us it's a kind of psychological
equilibrium so when we dream what we're
doing is the where we're going through
the process of taking this information
connecting it to emotional values and
weaving that into our subconscious and
that right there is the fertile ground
of metaphor that's where we're planting
our metaphors and that's where they grow
from so the dream is the render machine
for our lives and so what we what we do
and we're telling stories is we're
allowing ourselves to experience certain
things where we're watching a series of
events but that have emotional resonance
to us which is why it has such powerful
effects on a culture when when you tell
a story to a million people that's
that's imposing its offering up a new
way to look at the world and then if we
internalize it emotionally if we
sympathetically connect with it and we
allow it into our subconscious and if it
affects the way we develop our our
internal value systems are sacred and
profane then then it completely changes
the way we see the world and that's a
really powerful thing so ultimately when
we're when we're telling stories were
allowing ourselves we're trying to
engage that subconscious part of you
of us and draw it into the conscious and
change the way we have our value systems
can storytellers change the public
consciousness through manufacturing new
stories or do you think it has to be in
the public space and re-enacted in film
and TV can we manipulate let's let's
suppose society is on a downward spiral
in certain ways hmm
whether it's a new breed of terrorism
whether it's whatever people's isolation
through social media and being online
all the time
can we not in fact because that sounds
like a negative connotation but inject
new stories that could change certain
things or it has to follow what's
already out there in sort of the ether I
mean I'm I'm a pretty positive person I
think like the truth of it is is the
world is amazing right now
I mean politically speaking it seems
like it's this awful place and yes
people are behaving really badly but the
truth of it is if you look at the trends
are you familiar with Steven Pinker
enlightenment now so like read Pinker
read Chomsky compare both of them
compare contrasts you know I don't have
your oil teas either way but there's
really good information in both of their
writings generally speaking we have a
long way to go before we're genuinely
healthy robust communities that said
we're doing really well and as
storytellers it's an opportunity like we
we have opportunities every single day
even just in facebook posts or even in
writing samples or even in getting
online and talking about your situation
profoundly affects other people
emotionally so you know this is honestly
this is the time where we are inundated
with endless amounts of stories it's the
the image has never been powerful it's
interesting because like since the
internet you know I remember being asked
by this one student like you know do you
think illustration is dead is art dead
because you know it's all online and
it's all about film and animation I'm
like it the image has never been more
powerful like think a hundred years ago
like how how difficult it was to share
just a printed image now you can be
constantly producing stuff like you know
when I was a kid I dreamed of the day
where I could just find out about all
these artists that were pulling from
different stuff or reading all these
things like experiences that I had no
access to I'd have to go to a library or
something like that and I'd have to look
through endless amounts of books that's
kind of find stuff now go on Instagram
or go on Facebook or look at different
artists and stuff and so I think the
truth of it is we're in a really good
place people who are panicking because
they're always panicking it always feels
like the end of the world because we're
living on the edge of eternity like
we're right at the edge looking over
looking over having no idea what's going
to happen tomorrow that's just the human
condition but the reality is we're doing
really well and we're learning a lot and
ultimately as storytellers as writers
we're doing everything we can to
generate new metaphors to help us to go
into the dark night that's not a corny
but I see what you're saying I mean it
because not only that is the
preservation of images because like for
me I wanted to look up an old shopping
mall that was in the bay area that I
used to go to as a teenager and I think
had been demolished it was there it was
part of the it malls of the 80s that
were and I didn't realize there was an
entire Pinterest group dedicated to or
you know so and I could relive these
memories that would be long lost because
it brought out oh I remember this spot I
remember going to this Sears I remember
all these different things all of that
people had preserved them they had put
them up someone had a blog about you
know and and all of that so in some
sense that's great because some of that
would be lost yeah you know and but yeah
I mean I'm not trying to paint it in
such a dark way but I just wonder you're
so pessimist yeah well sorry we're how
can we can we how can we manipulate
things in a good way not spin things in
a bad way
we're I'm gonna skip you know current
news events where stuff could be spun to
make you think a certain way but what if
we were able to spin things almost like
thank you for smoking but in a great way
not not and I realize it's about me no
that is that's largely what rhetoric is
rhetoric is about presenting information
in a way that persuades people to comply
with you but you know to me what really
great art is and what we what everybody
decides what they want to do with their
art and what they want to do with with
their stories and I don't think people
should be telling other people what to
write or what not to write you get to
decide how you're going to engage the
market and the market gets to decide
whether you're relevant or not but um
but ultimately the stories that are you
know asking important questions that are
challenging important questions I
believe you know bringing truth
challenging existing beliefs challenging
values is one of the most powerful
things we can do and and we can do that
through entertainment entertainment is
the way that we engage other people's
minds
and by by exploring stories that
challenge us that excite us that inspire
us then we find I think ultimately then
we find a more healthy way of looking at
the world because you know one of the
biggest battles we have in humanity is
to overcome our own biases and I think
story is the perfect mechanism to do
that but you know and it really just
comes down to everybody just following
your passions you know Campbell the
schedules follow your bliss I'm more
interested in finding my fascination and
following the fascination when people
talk about writer's block and stuff like
that a lot of that is about like you
know letting the metaphor bake long
enough so it's ready but part of that
also is keying in to your fascination
like what is it that fascinates you
about
a hitman or a serial killer or you know
a woman that's leading a March or
something like that like that's those
are some sort of historical experience
once you engage the fascination then if
you're being completely honest with
yourself you're going to find a way to
tell the story that that's meaningful to
you